débutés l'audition des ministres je
voudrais souhaiter la bienvenue dans
notre commission à notre collègue daniel
breuiller ici sénateur du val de marne
daniel breuiller succède ainsi à notre
collègue sophie taille et pau lyon qui
comme vous le savez a été élu député
je voudrais
je voudrais remercier
nos collègues qui ont pu venir ce
vendredi matin puisqu'à la suite divers
événements et modifications de
calendrier
nous nous retrouvons se rendre du matin
salue évidemment nos collègues parisiens
de la région parisienne qui ont fait
l'effort et tout particulièrement les
lui tout de même de la bretagne qui ne
fait c'est quand même beau
ainsi que tous nos collègues qui sont
bien sûr en vidéo
bien monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général chers collègues nous
recevons ce matin donc monsieur bruno le
maire ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique et monsieur
gabriel attal ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics
ceci afin de nous présenter oserais je
dire enfin le projet de règlement du
budget et d'approbation des comptes de
l'année 2021 et surtout le projet de loi
de finances rectificative pour 2022
présenté hier après midi en conseil des
ministres je félicite en votre nom bruno
le maire pour sa reconduction dans ses
fonctions étendues et souhaite la
bienvenue à gabriel attal qui
s'exprimera tout à l'heure pour la
première fois devant nous dans ses
nouvelles fonctions
je forme évidemment le veut comme vous
messieurs les ministres que cette
audition soit le début des échanges
utiles et fructueux entre notre
commission et le gouvernement
comme vous le savez notre commission a
donc regretté que le gouvernement n'ait
pas présenté le projet de loi de
règlement dans les délais prescrits par
la loi organique c'est à dire le 1er
juin certain c'est pas la première fois
mais dans un gouvernement qu on pourrait
situer comme état en continuation vous
pouvez peut-être l'espérer il s'agissait
aussi d'une période pré électorale n'a
pas échappé mais il aurait été pourtant
nécessaire de faire dès ce moment là
c'est à dire fin du mois de mai
un bilan de l'exécution budgétaire avec
l'appui de la cour des comptes
alors que le gouvernement n'a cessé à
juste titre est encore tout récemment
s'en souvient lors du toilettage de la
lolf d'inviter les parlementaires à se
pencher davantage sur les résultats de
la gestion publique et que le sénat y
était prêt nous serons contraints de
réaliser cette année un examen des
comptes de manière
particulièrement expéditive
ceci est d'autant plus regrettable que
nous devons examiner dans des délais
également très contraint un important
projet de loi de finances rectificative
donc vous allez nous parler ce matin
essentiellement qu'il bouleverse les
équilibres du budget de l'état en 2022
le plfr actes en effet une forte
révision à la baisse de nos prévisions
de croissance de 4% à 2 5% il propose le
rappellerai une augmentation de dépenses
à hauteur de 44,2 milliards d'euros dont
20 milliards d'euros de mesures
nouvelles pour le pouvoir d'achat afin
de contrecarrer les effets de
l'inflation en face les estimations de
recettes sont en hausse mais pas
suffisamment cependant pour compenser
les dépenses nouvelles et des reports de
crédits de 2021 viendront aggraver
également le déficit
avant de vous laisser la parole pour
nous détailler ces dispositions je
voudrais dire que je m'interroge à titre
personnel sur deux points le premier
concerne les recettes supplémentaires
dont vous avez estimé dans la presse que
c'est la démonstration je vous cite
qu'une politique tournée vers les
baisses d'impôts et le travail produit
de la richesse et du financement pour la
protection des français pour ma part je
pense qu'il ya surtout qu'il s'agit d'un
effet de rattrapage qui n'est pas de
fait un phénomène durable aussi pensez
vous que l'approfondissement des baisses
d'impôts que j'ai pu qualifier
et j'y viens chaque fois de désarmement
fiscale reste soutenable à l'heure où
les conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
et les impératifs de transition
énergétique et de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat nécessite indubitablement un
important soutien public
le second concerne l'articulation de vos
propositions avec le redressement des
finances publiques la crise sanitaire a
marqué évidemment l'avènement du quoi
qu'il en coûte mais vous avez dit
récemment que la france avait atteint sa
cote d' alerte sur les finances
publiques
pour autant ce plfr sera encore pour
l'essentiel financé par la dette
comment résoudre cette contradiction
quel levier comptez vous utiliser au
moment où la croissance pour les années
2000 23 2024 n'apparaît pas pour le
moins assuré bien sûr nous aurons ce
débat essentiellement lors du plf
2023 messieurs les ministres nous allons
vous écoutez donc avec beaucoup
d'intérêt comme toujours avant d'en
venir aux questions du rapporteur
général et de l'ensemble des sénateurs
cette audition vous le savez bien
évidemment retransmise sur le site
internet du sénat
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
vous dire aussi tout le plaisir que j'ai
vous retrouvez à la présidence de
commission des finances et tout le
plaisir que j'ai retrouvé les sénatrices
et les sénateurs membres de la
commission nous devons double excuses la
première effectivement pour le retard
dans la présentation qui est lié aux
événements politiques et la deuxième
pour l'organisation d'une séance de
votre commission à vendredi matin ce qui
ce n'est pas le plus pratique mais qui
est liée là aussi aux contraintes de
calendrier tout cas je veux vous redire
à quel point je suis heureux de vous
retrouver et de travailler avec vous
comme nous l'avons fait depuis
maintenant plus de cinq ans
nous sommes comme vous le savez au coeur
du pic inflationniste
cette inflation elle a démarré à
l'automne dernier et la première raison
de l'inflation c'était la vigueur de la
reprise économique post co vide
elle nous a amené la france à
prendre des mesures de réponse qui ont
été les premières en europe et les
premières dans la zone euro plafonnement
du prix de l'électricité à 4% gel des
prix du gaz ces mesures massives qui
représente plus de 20 milliards d'euros
de dépenses à date nous ont permis
d'avoir l'inflation la plus faible de la
zone euro j'insiste là dessus nous avons
anticipé l'inflation et nous avons
protégé nos compatriotes contre
l'inflation avec un dispositif unique en
europe gel des prix du gaz plafonnement
des prix de l'électricité
si nous ne l'avions pas fait les
français auraient vu leur facture de gaz
augmenter de 50% et leur facture
d'électricité augmenter de 35%
donc nous avons été efficaces dans la
réponse à l'inflation parce que nous
avons anticipé les choses aient pris des
mesures massives
maintenant cette inflation s'accélère
s accélère pour des raisons
conjoncturelles la guerre en ukraine et
elle s'accélère aussi reconnaissons le
pour des raisons structurelles avec les
problèmes d'approvisionnement sur les
chaînes de production la fermeture du
marché chinois et l'accélération de la
transition écologique qui est très
coûteuse en termes inflationnistes
ce pic inflationniste devrait durer
plusieurs mois
au moins d'ici la fin de l'année 2022
nous anticipons ensuite une décrue de
l'inflation dans le courant de l'année
2023 pour revenir à la fin de l'année
2023 à niveau d'inflation qui sera moins
élevé qu'actuellement mais
structurellement plus élevé que celui
auquel nous étions habitués depuis des
années
dernier point sur lequel je veux
insister c'est que nous devons faire
preuve de beaucoup de modestie dans nos
prévisions le scénario que je vous
donnais notre scénario central
il y a évidemment d'autres scénarios qui
dépendent presque totalement de ce qui
se peut se passer en ukraine et des
événements géopolitiques sur
l'approvisionnement en matières
premières gaz et pétrole c'est notre
scénario central pic inflationniste de
plusieurs mois jusqu'à la fin et 2022
décrue à partir de l'année 2000 23 il y
à d'autres scénarios qui dépendent de la
situation en ukraine et des conditions
géopolitiques
d'approvisionnement en hydrocarbures
à partir de là dès lors que l'inflation
s'accroît il est légitime les justes de
protéger encore mieux deux compatriotes
et de prendre un certain nombre de
dispositions avec le projet de loi de
finances rectificative et le projet de
loi qui seront soumis à votre examen je
pense qu'on peut prendre de bonnes
décisions il faut avoir des principes
politiques donc cette décision repose
sur trois principes politiques le
premier c'est évidemment l'efficacité
l'inflation elle montre où elle devait
céder maîtriser ou n'est pas maîtrisée
nous avons maîtriser l'inflation grâce
au bouclier énergétique
nous maintiendrons donc l'intégralité du
bouclier énergétique jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2022 le président de la
république avait promis que les prix
électricité n'augmenteraient pas de plus
de 4 % chez qu'il y aura des
propositions dans le courant de l'été
nous n'augmenterons pas l'électricité
les tarifs d'électricité pour les
français le plafonnement à 4% sera
intégralement maintenue jusqu'à la fin
de l'année 2022 même chose pour les prix
du gaz ils n'augmenteront pas nous avons
décidé de geler les prix du gaz se
jetteront les prix du gaz jusqu'à la fin
de l'année 2022 et je redis qu'il n'y
aura pas de rattrapage si jamais les
prix devraient encore augmenter dans les
mois qui viennent eh bien nous en
tirerions les conséquences dans le
projet de loi de finances 2010 23 mais
ça ne figurera pas sur la facture du
consommateur
ça a un effet très vertueux ce bouclier
énergétique permet d'éviter à
l'inflation d'atteindre les niveaux
qu'elle atteint dans d'autres pays
européens la zone euro ça peut être 10
ou 11 %
hors de la zone euro cela peut aller
jusqu'à 15 16 17 20% l'inflation c'est
bien pour cela que nous prenons cette
décision en responsabilité elle est
coûteuse mais elle est efficace deuxième
principe la justice la justice et de
protéger ceux qui ont le plus besoin a
retraité qui touche la pension de
retraite comme celle de l'inflation
c'est une perte nette de pouvoir d'achat
pour lui il peut rien faire n'a pas
travailler davantage pour augmenter sa
pension de retraite donc il est légitime
de revaloriser des retraites et de les
indexées sur l'inflation
même chose pour les fonctionnaires
revaloriser le point d'indicé tout
simplement préserver le pouvoir d'achat
du traitement des fonctionnaires même
chose sur les minima sociaux il me
paraît tout à fait justes légitimes de
revaloriser ces minima sociaux et 2 m
dans ces minima sociaux ce qui en droit
n'est pas un minima social les
allocations familiales
tous ceux qui ont des enfants
aujourd'hui savent parfaitement que
l'augmentation du coût de l'alimentation
pèse terriblement sur les familles et
donc revaloriser les allocations
familiales c'est une mesure de justice
enfin le troisième point rejoint la
question qui m'a été posée par le
président et ce point est pour moi une
des lignes rouges forte de la discussion
qui sourd ce sont les finances publiques
ce paquet n'est pas financée par la
dette
la preuve en est que nous avions prévu
d'émettre de 160 milliards d'euros de
dettes en 2022 nous émettrons de 160
milliards d'euros de dettes ne lève pas
plus de dettes pour financer ce paquet
nous le finançons le président l'indiqué
grâce à des recettes fiscales
exceptionnelles qui sont liées à la
vigueur de la reprise et à la vigueur
des créations d'emplois qui sont le
fruit de notre politique
l'impôt ces sociétés où ils le rendement
est beaucoup plus élevé que prévu
les recettes sociales et de l'impôt sur
le revenu c'est 20 milliards d'euros de
recettes exceptionnelles
donc ça nous permet de financer des
mesures exceptionnelles et je vous
rejoins totalement ce n'est pas des
recettes durable c'est bien pour cela
que nous ne voulons pas mettre en face
de recettes exceptionnelles
des dépenses durable comme des baisses
de tva ou des baisses fiscales pérennes
qui pourraient poser des difficultés tu
es ensuite de financement quand on nous
dit qu'il faut plafonner le prix de
l'essence ou supprimer la tva j'ai
rarement vu un taux de tva qui baisse
qui puisse remonter ensuite donc là pour
le coup c'est des pertes de recettes
définitives
face à de nouvelles recettes
exceptionnelles donc je rejoins votre
raisonnement je fais deux exceptions et
on peut en débattre mais nous les
revendiquons avec gabriel atallah
je fais deux exceptions
n'ont pas tout et son contraire
contrairement aux républicains qui nous
propose de rétablir les finances
publiques et de dépenser 50 milliards
supplémentaires sur les sens ça c'est
tout et son contraire
mais pas vous j'ai entendu les propos
très responsable de même la sénatrice je
les ai repris à mon compte hier à
l'assemblée nationale
et je vous remercie de votre appui et ce
matin sur france info je vois que les
sénateurs suivent de manière aiguisée
comme toujours pour je m'égare non
l'exception
non mais on est vendredi matin et je
mets un peu d'animation
non les quels sont les deux exceptions
la contribution à l'audiovisuel public
parce qu'il me semble que c'est un impôt
quedate au regard de la manière dont nos
compatriotes ont accès aux médias et le
deuxième je tiens beaucoup on peut avoir
ce débat est un débat parfaitement
légitime ce sont les impôts de
production parce que je crois
profondément à la nécessité d'accélérer
la réindustrialisation du pays que nous
avons commencé cette baisse qu'elle est
réclamée par tous les industriels de
l'automobile de l'aéronautique de la
santé du médicament des semi conducteurs
et que moi je préfère les usines qui
ouvre en france que des usines qui ouvre
en allemagne et je ne peux pas ouvrir
des usines en france et des impôts de
production cette fois plus élevé qu'en
allemagne donc on peut en débattre mais
je pense qu'au bout du compte c'est plus
rentable y compris pour les finances
publiques de faire des baisses d'impôts
quand elles sont des investissements sur
l'industrie mais comme ça ça me permet
de répondre aux remarques
légitime comme toujours du président de
la commission des finances après quelles
sont les grandes lignes de ce paquet
pouvoir d'achat je vais être rapide
parce que vous les connaissez il ya 20
milliards d'euros de mesures
supplémentaires des indexations de
retraite du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires des allocations j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure il ya également
trois mesures qui visent les dépenses
contraintes les plus importants de nos
compatriotes la première c'est sur les
loyers devons échanger avec l'ensemble
des acteurs du logement social les
bailleurs privés des propriétaires
locataires et nous sommes parvenus à un
compromis pas de gel de lundi ce du prix
des loyers parce que ça se saurait
empêcher la construction de nouveaux
logements pas de hausse correspondant à
l'inflation parce que ça aurait amené
une augmentation des loyers de 6% qui
aurait été insupportable pour nos
compatriotes les plus modestes mais un
plafonnement à 3 25% pour un an entre le
1er octobre 2022 et le 1er octobre 2023
les loyers ne pourront pas augmenter de
plus de 3 et 2 5% au lieu des six qui
était prévu deuxième mesure l'indemnité
carburant
vous la connaissez
quel est l'objectif c'est de passer d'un
dispositif général et coûteux un
dispositif ciblé plus économes et plus
juste il repose et on peut en débattre
parce que celle encore tout le mérite de
nos institutions démocratiques c'est un
vrai choix politique que je revendique
que j'assume d'aider ceux qui
travaillent en priorité
donc cette indemnité n'est que pour ceux
qui travaillent pour des salariés pour
des ouvriers des ingénieurs pour des
alternants elle concernera aussi ceux
qui sont à la recherche d'un emploi via
pôle emploi et elle va se substituer
progressivement un dispositif très
général donc à partir du 1er octobre
nous ferons décroître
la compensation de 18 centimes elle
passera à 12 centimes en octobre 6
centimes en novembre et elle disparaîtra
au mois de décembre et dès le 1er
octobre tous ceux qui ont un véhicule
pourront aller sur le site de la dgesip
donner le numéro d'immatriculation leur
véhicule déclaré car ça se fera sur une
base déclaratoire qu'ils utilisent leur
véhicule pour aller travailler il y aura
des contrôles aléatoires
nous disposons grâce aux entreprises des
informations nécessaires pour faire des
contrôles aléatoires mais ce sera sur
une base déclaratoire par souci de
simplicité et tous les salariés
concernés tous les fonctionnaires
concernés tous et alternant concerner
toutes les professions indépendantes
concernés qu utilise un véhicule pour en
toucher entre 100 et 300 euros en
fonction de leur niveau de roeux nous
proposons que cela concerne tous les
salariés français toutes les personnes
qui travaillent jusqu'à 5e décile
on peut en débattre
nous nous proposons de 5e décile
c'est-à-dire 1260 euros nets par mois
pour une personne seule comme revenu
enfin le troisième poste de dépense
important c'est l'alimentation ne
mettrons en place un chèque alimentaires
de 100 euros + 50 euros par enfant à la
rentrée enfin toujours pour ceux qui
travaillent nour valoriseront la prime
d'activité à 4%
nos b seront les cotisations sociales
pour les indépendances une promesse qui
a été faite par le président de la
république à lui de paix il ya quelques
mois nous mettrons en place une prime
qui pourra aller jusqu'à 6000 euros pour
les entreprises qui disposent d'un
accord d'intéressement et nous
simplifieront les accords
d'intéressement voilà quelles sont les
grandes lignes de ces deux textes qui
seront soumis à votre examen vous me
permettrez rajouter deux éléments de
conclusion le premier c'est sur les
finances publiques
je redis que tout n'est pas possible
financièrement
et que on peut échanger sur les mesures
pourquoi pas
réduire une mesure pour en accentuer
notre on peut réorienter des crédits et
discuté de l'efficacité de mesures ou
d'autres moi je suis tout à fait prêt à
cela mais en revanche rajouter à chaque
fois des milliards et des milliards pour
avoir un paquet qui soit plus lourd ben
c'est tout simplement plomber nos
comptes publics donc ça ne me semble pas
la bonne direction nous avons une
trajectoire je suis garant de cette
trajectoire si je viens de 5% déficit en
2021 5 en 2022 3 en 2027 et il est
évident que tout dérapage en 2022 2 de
la dépense publique et du déficit public
rendre est inatteignable l'objectif de
3% de déficit en 2027 alors comme je
souhaite que nous puissions tenir cet
objectif je ne veux pas de dérapage des
finances publiques à l'occasion de
l'examen de ces deux textes enfin
deuxième élément mais qui est important
je les ai dit à plusieurs reprises le
fardeau doit être équitablement partagés
l'état fait beaucoup
certaines entreprises ont commencé à
faire beaucoup je pense à l'hôtellerie
la restauration qui est bien valorisé
ses salaires et ses salariés mais je
pense que toutes les entreprises qui le
peuvent je dis bien qu'ils le peuvent
doivent augmenter les salaires ou les
rémunérations de leurs salariés en
utilisant les instruments mis à leur
disposition
que ce soit les primes exceptionnelles
ou l'intéressement et la participation
j'ai le ministre riel attal merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs cette audition porte à la fois
sur le plfr que vient de présenter bruno
le maire et sur le projet de loi de
règlement pour
2021 et donc je vais faire une rapide
présentation de ce texte pour revenir en
quelques mots sur l'exécution budgétaire
de l'année dernière je vais d'abord
mettre en relief plusieurs éléments et
plusieurs enseignements pour vous
redonner les points d'atterrissage au
travers de quelques chiffres l'année
2021 a été à la fois celle de la
protection de la relance et de la
maîtrise protection des agents
économiques relance de l'activité et
maîtrise de nos comptes tout ceci dans
un contexte
macro-économique singulier puisque nous
avons eu à la fois les vents favorables
de la reprise et les effets néfastes de
la surchauffe je veux néanmoins relevé
qu'avec une croissance de 6 8% notre
pays fait 1 4 points de mieux que la
moyenne de la zone euro et c'est le
résultat des choix politiques et
budgétaires que nous avons fait cette
exécution budgétaire témoigne d'abord
des moyens mis en oeuvre pour protéger
les entreprises et les ménages notamment
les plus fragiles durant toute cette
période nous avons tout fait pour ne pas
ajouter de la ville de la vulnérabilité
financière à la vulnérabilité sanitaires
je pense notamment aux 3 8 milliards
d'euros mobilisés pour verser une
indemnité inflation de 100 euros à 38
millions de français ou encore aux 600
millions d'euros engagés pour verser un
chèque énergie exceptionnelle à 5 6
millions de foyers modestes juste avant
les fêtes de fin d'année vous vous en
souvenez s'agissant de la protection des
entreprises et donc des femmes et des
hommes qui les font vivre nous avons
durant ces mois de stop and go
pandémique constamment adapter nos
dispositifs
je pense en particulier à l'activité
partielle dont ont bénéficié 3,5
millions de salariés au global nous
avons mobilisé en 2021 34 milliards
d'euros dans le cadre de la mission plan
d'urgence face à la crise sanitaire nous
avons permis à nos entreprises de tenir
le choc de ne pas manquer de trésorerie
de continuer à investir et d'embauché je
vais aussi retenir l'effort de relance
dans cette loi de règlement dans ce
projet de loi de règlement témoigne avec
72 milliards d'euros engagés sur les
sens du plan relance nous avons agi vite
et fort pour accélérer la transition
énergétique pour renforcer la
compétitivité et le dynamisme de nos
industries mais aussi pour favoriser
l'insertion professionnelle des jeunes
je pense en particulier au plan un jeune
une solution dont se sont emparés
environ 4 millions de jeunes l'année
dernière enfin s'agissant de la tenue de
nos comptes l'année 2021 a été marquée
par une réduction du déficit public de
2,5 points de pipe je rappelle c'était 8
9 % en 2020 essai de 6 4% en 2021 c'est
un effort que nous allons poursuivre
cette année avec un objectif qui a
rappelé bruno le maire de 5% des crues
du déficit et des crues de la dette
également qui s'établit à 112 5 % du
pipe fin décembre soit deux points de
moins que l'année précédente
s'agissant du solde budgétaire de l'état
celui-ci ressort en amélioration de 7 3
milliards d'euros et s'établit à
170,7 milliards d'euros en comptabilité
budgétaire je vais également partager
avec vous le surplus de recettes
fiscales dont nous avons bénéficié grâce
à la vigueur de la reprise par rapport à
nos prévisions se sont un peu plus de 37
milliards d'euros de recettes fiscales
supplémentaires que nous avons encaissés
grâce au dynamisme et ça a été rappelé
aussi de liesse de la tva et de l'hyères
au global 2021 a donc été l'année 1 de
la remise en ordre des comptes publics
poste kovy des postes quoi qu'il en
coûte après la déflagration sanitaires
que nous avons connue et nous allons
poursuivre sur cette voie en 2022 très
rapidement sur le plfr bruno le maire a
présenté les mesures principales sur le
pouvoir d'achat je rappelle que c'est un
paquet global il ya le plfr il ya le
projet de loi sur le pouvoir d'achat il
ya par ailleurs des mesures qui sont
prises de façon réglementaire exemple
l'augmentation du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires un décret a été adopté
hier en conseil des ministres les
crédits sont évidemment inscrits ou plfr
mais c'est bien un décret qui a pris la
mesure au delà des mesures de pouvoir
d'achat et de lutte contre l'inflation
qui a présenté bruno le maire ce plfr
comporte plusieurs mesures pour tenir
compte de la situation du marché de
l'énergie pour lutter contre la fraude
pour soutenir nos entreprises dans le
contexte de la guerre en ukraine et pour
aider l'ukraine elle même d'abord le
texte entérine le déplafonnement de
certains contrats d'énergie
renouvelables pour tenir compte de la
hausse récente des prix de l'électricité
et donc permettre à l'état vous savez
selon le système qui a été mise en place
de percevoir la totalité des sommes dues
par les producteurs au titre de contrats
signés entre 2016 et 2019
l'article sécurisé donc ce
déplafonnement via une validation
législative pour la période du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre 2022 se déplacent
fondement des versements des producteurs
à l'état représente pour l'état un gain
de 2,4 milliards d'euros au titre de
l'année 2022 en matière de
simplification
administrative et de lutte contre la
fraude ce texte remet aussi sur les
rails la généralisation de la
facturation électronique vous savez
c'est un grand chantier qui a été
initiée par mes prédécesseurs il s'agit
d'une rapporte d'une réforme majeure
porteuse de gains d'efficience important
d'au moins 4,5 milliards d'euros par an
pour les entreprises tels qu'ils ont été
estimés mais aussi de rentrées fiscales
supplémentaires pour l'état puisqu'elle
permettra cette facture fait cette
facturation électronique de lutter
contre la fraude à la tva enfin pour
soutenir la trésorerie des enfants des
entreprises affectées par le conflit en
ukraine ce plfr prolonge l'octroi de la
garantie de l'état au 31 décembre 2022
pour les pge résilience en matière de
soute un soutien apporté aux acteurs
économiques également 1,5 milliard
d'euros de crédits sont ouverts pour
financer les mesures de soutien aux
entreprises dites energo intensive ce
sont les entreprises qui consomme
énormément d'énergie plus de 3% de leur
chiffre date de change chiffre
d'affaires consacré à des dépenses
d'électricité ou de gaz et dont la
facture d'électricité ou de gaz sur la
période de référence a été doublé par
rapport à l'année 2000 21 ces
entreprises sont très fragilisées par la
hausse des prix de l'électricité et du
gaz et donc nous leur apportons une aide
spécifique qui a été ouverte je le
rappelle en début de semaine et les
entreprises éligibles peuvent demander
l'aide sur le site de la dg fils depuis
début de la semaine ce plfr n'oublie pas
non plus d'aider l'ukraine pays meurtri
par la guerre exemple sur un plan
économique il ouvre 315 millions d'euros
de crédits pour permettre à l'agencé
française de développement d'accorder
des aides de 300 millions d'euros à
l'ukraine est de 15 pour la république
de moldavie je rappelle aussi que parmi
les ouvertures du décret d'avancé du 7
avril 2022 que ce plfr ratifie se
trouvait déjà 400 millions d'euros de
crédits pour financer les surcoûts liés
à l'accueil dé ducret en france pour
financer le versement d'une allocation
de subsistance lada et l'ouverture de
centres d'hébergement je ne serai pas
complet mais j'en termine par la cie je
ne rappelais pas que ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative est aussi
l'occasion d'ouvrir des crédits pour la
politique publique de l'apprentissage
dont 1,8 milliard d'euros pour france
compétences et près de 750 millions
d'euros pour les primes apprentissage ce
qui reflète ainsi le dynamisme de cette
politique qui est une grande réussite
des dernières années moins de 300 milles
apprentis par an en 2010 est plus de
700000 aujourd'hui est partout sur le
territoire les entreprises et nos jeunes
nous le disent c'est un très grand
succès 2 milliards d'euros prévus au
titre des dotations pour événements
accidentels et imprévisible chacun peut
le comprendre pour parer à toute
éventualité dans un monde et bruno le
maire l'a rappelé encore fortement
marqué par une incertitude liée à la
situation internationale et économique
500 millions d'euros aussi dédié à
l'agriculture pour venir en aide aux
forces vives qui produisent pour nourrir
la france et qui ont subi les aléas
divers
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres
d'abord je vais m'associer
aux propos du président vous souhaitant
la bienvenue
pour un ministre dans la continuité de
son action bruno le maire et à gabriel
attal également bienvenue donc dans
notre assemblée dont vous savez quel le
est là pour habitude de travailler avec
sérieux mais également avec une grande
vigilance et nous poursuivrons en nous
mettant comme vous rapidement au travail
puisque nous disposons le président l'a
rappelé enfin des éléments que nous
attendions depuis un long moment mais
j'ai compris que la première ministre
béret à améliorer
modifier les habitudes d'hier donc
bousserez je pense messieurs les
ministres toujours les bienvenus dans
cette maison
je voulais faire quelques quelques
observations d'abord une première sur
l' hypothèse d'inflation que vous avez
retenu qui est qui est la vôtre c'est le
scénario central 5% pour l'année 2022 là
où l'insee prévoit l 5 6%
qu'est ce qui a motivé
ce de retenir ce choix qui est surtout
qu'elle
quel serait le coût de ce différentiel
pour nos finances publiques dont je me
plais à entendre mais j'aurai l'occasion
d'y revenir dans quelques instants
l'attachement au redressement des
comptes monsieur le ministre nous le
maire que vous avez rappelé donc le coût
de ce différentiel notamment par les
effets sur les obligations indexées ou
bien encore les mesures de soutien aux
ménages puisque on a bien compris que
tout ça n'était pas neutre
deuxième observation
vous l'indiquez et vous le répéter à
l'envi depuis quelque temps un peu en
forme d'aveu la cote d'alerté est
atteinte pour les finances publiques si
je comprends bien lorsqu'elle est
atteinte elle est même dépassée et j'ai
bien entendu vos propos hier devant la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
vous vous avez affirmé la nécessité de
compter chaque euro dans l'état actuel
et qu'il nous fallait donc tenir compte
du fait évidemment que les conditions de
financement en changer
mais avez vous monsieur le ministre
réellement le sentiment que ce plfr
traduit vos propos je vais je vais
m'appuyer sur un exemple le plfr ouvre
des crédits nouveaux sur une centaine de
programmes du budget général pour un
total de plus de 47 milliards montant
brut et non annuler que sur un seul
programme celui de l'évaluation de la
charge d'intérêts de sncf réseau pour 9
millions d'euros alors
certes il s'agit aussi pour vous de
rétablir les crédits annulés dans le
cadre du décret d'avancé pour financer
la remise de 18 centimes en avril
dernier mais cela signifie t'il aussi
que vous n'avez pas pu identifier un
seul programme du budget mairal en
dehors des crédits ablatif que je viens
de mentionner sur lesquels les crédits
aurait pu être annulé de manière à
compenser et au moins partiellement les
ouvertures de crédits nécessaires sur
d'autres dispositifs
12 milliards
sont prévus pour les participations
financières de l'état
or la première ministre dans sa
déclaration de politique générale a
annoncé l'intention de l'état de détenir
100% du capital d'edf
là encore hier vous avez indiqué devant
nos collègues députés que les 12
milliards d'euros correspondait à
l'acquisition des actions manquantes
d'edf ainsi qu'à d'éventuelles d'autres
opérations quel est donc concrètement le
montant qui est prévu pour l'opération
lie à edf et selon quels critères des
participations financières serait-elle
envisagée pour d'autres opérations
je voudrais abl évoqué également le dans
ce plfr la suppression confirmée dès
2022 de la contribution à l'audiovisuel
public
vous la présenter comme une mesure de
pouvoir d'achat je dirais c'est relatif
puisque si on regarde le gard elles pour
les ménages concernés je rappelle que
près de 5 millions de foyers sont d'ores
et déjà exonérés du paiement de cette
contribution
une suppression qui était d'ailleurs
largement dissipé mais qui souffre de
manques et de carence puisque le
gouvernement s'était engagé en 2019 à
présent un rapport sur l'avenir de ce
prélèvement devant le parlement
le document n'a jamais été publiée en
octobre de l'an dernier une mission
conjointe inspection des finances
et inspection générale des affaires
culturelles devait rendre des
conclusions absence complète
vous parlez de transparence c'est mieux
de travailler effectivement en bonne
intelligence et en donnant les chiffres
r les mettant à la connaissance de nos
aux assemblées donc j'ai le sentiment
sur ce sujet d'être plutôt dans une
politique du fait accompli alors je vous
reconnais au moins le courage de vous
attaquer une modernisation du secteur de
l'audiovisuel public
ce qu'il faut savoir maintenant c'est
comment allez vous procéder pour 2023
gmail un peu plus loin je pense que
plutôt que de supprimer sans donner de
je dirais les ressources sont donnés de
choix alternatifs
il eût été préférable
peut-être d'y aller progressivement
justement en travaillant en partage avec
les deux assemblées
cinquième et dernier point à ce stade
4 milliards 6 sont proposées dans ce
projet de loi de finances pour la mise
en place d'un dispositif de soutien aux
travailleurs qui dispose d'un véhicule
c'est un peu c'est pas tout à fait la
moitié 2 milliards et puis la
prolongation de la remise sur le prix
des carburants à la pompe 2 milliards 6
dans le dossier de presse on a des
indications qui sont plus précises et
vous les avez évoqué rapidement sur le
ciblage notamment des personnes qui
roulent beaucoup et qui sont des
personnes actives ça c'est pour
remplacer la remise actuelle et pour
laquelle deux milliards sont fléchés
mais j'ai entendu dont vous allez
certainement nous donner d'autres
précisions il semblerait qu'il ne soit
pas les seuls les actifs en bénéficier
puisque vous avez parlé d'un certain
nombre de professions vous avez faim de
profession nombre de personnes qui
notamment les retraités qui évidemment
lorsqu'il roule encore haineux et sont
dans des territoires où en plus n'ont
pas de choix alternatifs
vous indiquez
depuis hier que les parlementaires
pourront faire près part de leur volonté
et essayer de fixer vous l'avez encore
évoqué il ya quelques instants le
curseur pour les rouleurs entre
guillemets concernés et le montant qui
pourrait correspondre à chaque niveau
mais il ya il ya une question c'est dans
quelle mesure dès lors que le projet de
loi ne prévoit pas de dispositif en dur
et uniquement des crédits budgétaires
puisque vous savez quand même que nous
sommes contraints par la recevabilité
financière de nos amendements donc la
question c'est de quelle marge de
manoeuvre si ce n'est en dehors d'une
forme de bavardage qui pourrait être un
peu intempestifs à contretemps disposons
nous vraiment raison pour laquelle je
m'interroge sur la capacité de dialogue
et les ouvertures auquel vous êtes
disposé messieurs les ministres
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
alors jour indique avant de donner la
parole au ministre pour les premières
réponses au rapporteur général que j'ai
neuf inscrits 10 je n'irai pas plus loin
merci
donc dix inscrits donc les fissures ont
à peu près une minute trente alors
essayé essayé d'être est d'être dans la
synthèse le plus possible et dans la
question je vous rappelle que nous
posons des questions
merci monsieur le monsieur mais j'essaie
de respecter le temps d un des uns et
des autres monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le rapporteur général pour vos
questions et très heureux de continuer
aussi
avec vous pour les années qui viennent
cinq questions j'apporterai quatre
réponses et gabriel vous répondra sur la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
l'hypothèse inflation nous avons retenu
est une hypothèse effectivement à 5%
celles de l'insee à 5,6 tout simplement
parce que nous avons une évaluation
différente sur le prix du baril l'insee
air aux primes ni potez 120 dollars le
baril nous unit potez 114 dollars le
baril je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui le
baril est à 108 dollars donc nous sommes
légèrement au dessus d'eux
cours du marché
nous continuerons à suivre ça de près
mais je pense que l'hypothèse
aujourd'hui est raisonnable et
correspond à la situation du marché
s'agissant de la charge de la dette
c'est la raison principale pour laquelle
j'ai dit que nous avons atteint la côte
d'alerté
je revendique le quoi qu'il en coûte
nous a permis d'éviter un dérapage de la
dette parce que indemniser des
entreprises et à indemniser les chômeurs
c'est plus coûteux que de les protéger
avant en revanche nous avons mis en
place quoi qu'il en coûte avec des taux
d'intérêt à zéro
voire négatifs
des situations ayant radicalement changé
et une partie de la dette française
étant comme vous l'avez rappelé indexées
sur l'inflation nous ne pouvons plus
continuer comme cela ça n'est pas
possible ce serait pas responsable dans
l'est de cesse de le rappeler un point
d'inflexion en plus c'est 2 25 milliards
d'euros de charges à des supplémentaires
en raison de l'indexation d'une partie
notre dette 10 % précisément sur
l'inflation et je rappelle que dans
cette partie de la dette avec ses sur
l'inflation et deux tiers sont indexés
sur le niveau d'inflation moyen la zone
euro qui est très supérieur aux niveaux
d'inflation de la france c'est ce qui
nous amène à inscrire 12 milliards
d'euros de charges de la dette
supplémentaire en raison de l'inflation
donc ça doit nous amener effectivement
comme vous l'avez rappelé à faire preuve
de beaucoup de sens des responsabilités
sur les économies je partage ce que vous
dite je pense qu'il est important au
delà de la première réponse pour
rétablir les finances publiques qui le
plein emploi est la réponse de loin la
plus efficace qui suppose qui suppose
des décisions structurelles réforme des
retraites assurance chômage mais qui
suppose aussi des dépenses à réduire et
je donne rendez-vous pour le plf 2010 23
je pense qu'il est important que dans ce
travail collectif que nous ouvrons sur
la méthode qui a défini la première
ministre nous puissions travailler tous
ensemble à identifier les gisements de
dépenses publiques qui pourraient être
réduite dans les années qui viennent et
nous permettent de tenir un engagement
de 3 % de déficit je leur dis cette
trajectoire doit être tenu elle doit
être tenu pour notre indépendance
nationale il ne peut être retenu que
s'il n'y a pas de dérapage en 2022 et
que si nous arrivons à créer le plein
emploi dans notre pays a engagé des
réformes de structure et à identifier
effectivement un certain nombre de
dépenses a réduit s'agissant des
participations de l'état c'est la seule
réponse sur laquelle j'ai peur de vous
décevoir parce que je ne peux pas donner
que c'est une opération qui est en cours
préciser exactement le montant qui sera
consacré à la nationalisation d'edf dans
ces 12 et 2 7 milliards d'euros qui
comprennent la nationalisation d'edf et
d'autres opérations sur les titres de
l'état qui pourrait être nécessaire dans
le courant de l'année en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation économique à
son entreprise que nous n'avons pas
laissé tomber depuis le début de la
crise et que nous ne laisserons jamais
tomber
enfin sur le soutien ou travailleur je
redis que les paramètres peuvent être
discutées dès aujourd'hui pour améliorer
le dispositif
pour être tout à fait précis je redis
qu'il est réservé aux personnes qui
travaillent que soient indépendants
salariés fonctionnaires alternant pour
être tout à fait précis pour les déciles
1 2 et 3 ce sera une aide de 200 euros
pour les déciles 4 et 5 une aide de 100
euros avec une majoration de 50% si
jamais votre
de travail particulièrement éloigné de
votre domicile est ce qu'il faut aller
plus loin sur les déciles moins loin en
concentrant les forts ça je trouve que
c'est un débat qui est particulièrement
utile et nous pourrons je vous le
confirme améliorer ensemble ce
dispositif enfin sur les retraités c'est
un choix politique et nous avons indexer
les retraites nous augmentons de 4% et
nous concentrons l'effort sur les
déplacements sur des personnes qui
travaillent soient bons choix politique
peut être discutée mais c'est le choix
que nous proposons aux parlementaires
merci monsieur le ministre nous ouvrons
donc
pardon excusez moi c'est le ministre
peut-être peut-être très rapidement
d'abord sur la question du rapporteur
général sur les annulations de crédits
effectivement c'est un plfr qui a
principalement pour objet d'ouvrir des
crédits pour répondre à la crise de
l'inflation compte tenu des aléas qui
reste quand même assez massif du en
raison de la situation géopolitique et
économique internationale je pense que
c'est principalement plfr de fins de
gestion que des annulations éventuelles
de crédit pourront être constatée est
réalisé sur la cape il y aura un vrai
beau débat parlementaire sur la manière
de compenser donner les garanties
attendues par les sociétés de
l'audiovisuel public je vais regarder me
renseigner sur les rapports que vous
évoquez et sur les raisons pour
lesquelles ils ne vous ont pas été
communiqués en réalité il ya eu
énormément de travaux sur le sujet
notamment très bons rapports karoutchi
très récent karoutchi hugonnet il me
semble
voilà je crois que je pressens donc a eu
beaucoup de travaux beaucoup de
réflexion sur ce sujet là c'est vrai que
nous avons pris l'engagement dans le
cadre de la campagne présidentielle de
supprimer cet impôt parce que c'est un
impôt qui n'est pas tout à fait juste
puisque tout le monde paye la même chose
en fonction des revenus par ailleurs
c'est assez clair puisque souvent quand
on prend des mesures les français nous
disent vous prenez telles mesures au
niveau général qu'est ce que je vais en
voir - concrètement à là c'est clair
c'est très clair puisqu'il ne payerons
pas si le parlement adopte cette mesure
leur contribution à l'audiovisuel public
a à l'automne on soutient la question
des garanties vous voyez que dans le
projet de loi qui est présenté il y a
notamment de garanties importantes à la
création d'une mission budgétaire dédiée
de le fait que la subvention versée aux
sociétés de l'audiovisuel public le sera
dans un délai d'un mois à compter de
l'ouverture de la gestion intégralement
et non plus mensualisés comme c'était le
cas ce qui est une garantie importante
ensuite dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques je
pense qu'on sera capable de donner de la
visibilité aux sociétés de l'audiovisuel
public sur leurs budgets sur le
quinquennat et il ya évidemment aussi
l'outil des contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens qui va être pleinement déployée
merci
donc premier questionneur ou
intervenants jérôme bascher suivi de
roger karoutchi
merci monsieur le président rexecode 10
pour indiquer le déficit public
commençait par des hypothèses
économiques prudentes voilà un rapport
qu'il a sorti le 5 juillet alors il faut
commencer par redire ce qu'est la
macroéconomie aujourd'hui non monsieur
le ministre de l'économie ici à la
commission des finances et dès le
printemps 2021 nous avons dit que
l'inflation augmentait et vous pouvez
regarder la courbe en glissement elle
n'a pas changé la pente est toujours la
même depuis le premier semestre 2021 il
fallait écouter le sénat sur le rebond
de croissance monsieur le ministre du
budget vous nous dites en 2021 on a fait
mieux que les autres baril mais en 2020
on a fait pire que les autres et donc il
se trouve que fin 2010 9 comme
l'ensemble des pays européens
enfin 2021 nous avons retrouvé le même
niveau de pipe que fin 2019 donc rien de
mieux pas de cocorico
revenons sur la croissance potentielle
je prends de parler de mesures
structurelles je serai les autres parler
de démesure de pouvoir d'achat qui me
semble aussi importante moi je pense
qu'il faut aller un peu plus vers la
croissance potentielle c'est à dire ici
et maintenant vers plus de force de
travail car c'est de cela dans toutes
les entreprises toutes celles que nous
visitons nous disent nous cherchons est
à peu près 10% de salariés en plus 10 %
on n'est pas dans les masses à faire
pour aller vers le plein emploi et donc
pour cela je pense qu'il faudrait faire
des mesures pour les heures
supplémentaires afin que ce soit plus
attractif et que ce qu'on appelle le
coin salariale soit légèrement augmenté
alors quand on augmente le rsa 2 4% mais
par exemple le point tub fonction
publique de trois et demi je suis désolé
on ne fait pas ce qu'il faut en fait
l'un verse d'une bonne politique de
croissance potentiel pour l'emploi donc
je le regrette
alors
comment voulez-vous
refaisant des mesures de demandes
juguler l'inflation c'est quand même un
sujet majeur comment voulez vous faire
je n'ai pas compris la politique pour
juguler l'inflation que vous nous
proposez monsieur le ministre d'économie
monsieur le ministre du budget
en 2021 comme en 2020 il n'y avait pas
de suppressions d'emplois dans le budget
or à chaque fois nous avons des
suppressions d'emplois 10le
constatations 3500 emplois supprimés
dans le budget 2010 21 mais ne croyez
vous pas que ce soit vraiment au
parlement et à une politique clairement
dit de supprimer des emplois qu'il
faudrait afficher des le plf est ce que
c'est une politique j'ai envie de dire à
bas bruit pour réduire la masse
salariale dites le nous enfin pouvez
vous me confirmer monsieur le ministre
du budget que avec ce plfr
la deuxième mission de l'etat sera de
rembourser la dette avant la défense
nationale avant la défense nationale au
moment où l'europe est en guerre
merci jérôme roger karoutchi puis 20
chambres de l'est oui monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres
je vais essayer de rester dans ma minute
et demie d'abord monsieur le ministre de
l'économie monsieur le ministre de
l'économie quand vous êtes au sénat
naturellement vous débattez avec les
sénateurs et pas avec les députés donc
ce qui a pu être dit à l'assemblée
nationale ça n'est pas ce qui se dit ici
et ici j'ai cru comprendre que la
première ministre souhaitait être plus
dans le débat avec les sénateurs
comprenant que c'était ici que les
choses se passeraient sur le fond je
partage cette opinion et donc merci de
la partager aussi
deuxième élément rapidement monsieur le
ministre je rêverais d'accepter votre
scénario central mais permettez moi de
vous rappeler que bas tout ça est quand
même très dépendants lorsqu en 2017 vous
nous avez dit que le scénario central
était d'être à l'équilibré complet en
on vous a sinon cru du moins espérer
pouvoir vous croire naturellement les
choses n'ont pas été ce qui était
envisagé
triste du coc vide crise énergétique
tout tout tout ça est parfaitement
compréhensible mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui est-ce que le scénario le
plus optimiste est le plus crédible non
d'abord parce que la guerre en ukraine
continue parce que la pandémie de covin
n'est pas finie loin s'en faut parce que
la situation internationale reste très
troublée parce que en tout état de cause
vous avez acceptés à partir de septembre
un certain nombre de dialogue de
concertation avec les syndicats avec les
organisations agricoles avec l'ensemble
des choses qui vont naturellement vous
demander davantage de dépenses davantage
de salaire davantage de traitements et
vous ne pourrez pas dire non à tout ce
qui veut dire que les dépenses prévues
sont nettement supérieurs à vos rentrées
fiscales cette année ce qui nous laisse
un peu sceptique sur le 5 % de déficit
de cette année j'ai cru comprendre c'est
ma première question que l' agence de
les agences de notation étaient
inquiètes et envisageait d'abaisser la
note de la france à l'automne est-ce que
là dessus monsieur le ministre vous avez
des éléments
je vois que d'ailleurs ce matin est
annoncée un niveau record de déficit
commercial au mois de mai 13 milliards
sur la cape monsieur le ministre du
budget il ya eu effectivement
l'excellent rapport hugonnet karoutchi
je me mets en 2d par bonté d'âme mais
cet excellent rapport demandé certes
prenez acte à contrecoeur de la
suppression de la cape en disant bas une
fois de plus on ne parle pas d'abord du
périmètre et des missions on parle
d'abord du financement ce qui n'est pas
acceptable se savait des années qu'on
dit faut un vrai débat sur l'audiovisuel
ça fait des années qu'on ne parle que de
financement et pas d'émission et
deuxième élément le sénat a proposé qui
est un organisme indépendant de contrôle
de ce financement public je ne le vois
nulle part si ça devient une simple
mission budgétaire avec tous les aléas
que cela veut dire je comprendrais les
inquiétudes dans l'audiovisuel public
est ce que là dessus vous êtes prêt à
avancer
merci roger vincent delahaye puis pascal
savoldelli pardon
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres alors moi j'ai un regret
d'abord c'est laisser le temps de parole
qu'on nous laisse parce qu'il est très
court mais c'est le fait que l'on
mélange dans une même audition la loi de
règlement et le plfr je trouve ça fort
regrettable monsieur mise des comptes
publics a parlé cinq minutes à peine
cinq minutes de la loi de règlement moi
je considère que analyser le passé
éclaire l'avenir et qu'il serait bon
qu'on passe beaucoup plus de temps le
dit et chaque année mais c'est dommage
qu'on ne le fasse pas sur ses doigts de
règlement et moi je regrette ya pas de
document synthétique et là en plus en
2021 c'est la fin du quinquennat dont
vous pouvez avoir un bilan sur cinq ans
de la politique financière et budgétaire
de la france et c'était quand même
intéressant de voir un petit peu comme
ans avait évolué pendant cinq ans et pas
uniquement sur les deux dernières années
donc moi je vois là je considère que
c'est vraiment dommage alors après quand
on regarde les lauréats la loi de
règlement moi j'ai des questions sur les
prévisions et j'aimerais avoir beaucoup
plus de détails sur la façon dont on a
prévu les choses notamment la charge
d'intérêts monsieur ministre d'économie
vous nous avez donné quelques éléments
sur le l'impact de l'inflation il me
semblait effectivement que c'était 10 %
de la dette et que l'inflation n'avait
été que de 1,6 pour cent en 2021 donc
j'ai été surpris de l'augmentation de 5
milliards du du coût de la dette et du
coût des intérêts et bien sûr je suis
surpris des 55 milliards prévue en 2022
parce que là on va on va commencer à
sentir vraiment le coût de l'endettement
ce que l'on dénonce nous depuis des
années on dit faisons attention on ne
fait pas suffisamment attention et on va
voir que là ça va ça va déraper
fortement et ça va nous coûter très très
cher sur les recettes fiscales vous
dites c'est c'est le rebond de
l'activité moi je n'y crois pas moi je
crois que c'est une sous-estimation au
départ une sous-évaluation des recettes
dans le dans la loi de finances initiale
et j'avais demandé des précisions donc
moi est ce qu on pourrait avoir une note
synthétique qui nous disent entre les
prévisions et les réalisations
comment il avait été établi les
prévisions et comment elles ont évolué
sur l'impôt sur le revenu sur l'impôt
sur les sociétés et sur la tva parce que
seraient teva moi j'avais dénoncé
j'avais dit que c'était elle était
largement sous-évaluée dans la loi de
finances et je ne comprends vraiment pas
alors qu'on avait une croissance qui est
pas très éloignée de celle qui s'est
réalisé je ne comprends absolument pas
le rendu alors une autre question c'est
france compétences france compétences
quand est ce qu on arrivera à maîtriser
le déficit de france compétences est-ce
que tout a été pris en 2021 ce qui
devait être pris parce que moi je suis
toujours sur la dualité des budgétaire
et je suis pas sûr que ça a été le cas
mais bon voilà j'aimerais savoir si vous
êtes persuadé et dernière question sur
la loi de règlement c'est
les dépenses protocolaire mois ces
dépenses qui m'intéresse j'ai toujours
du mal à les avoir combien on a dépensé
en communication en frais de déplacement
en relations publiques en 2021 cocon
bien combien on a atteint et quelles
variation par rapport à 2020 enfin d'une
façon plus générale quel est le montant
de
l' épargne supplémentaire que les
français ont mis de côté en 2020 et 2021
et pensez vous qu'il y a un vrai
problème de pouvoir d'achat pour tous
les français moi je dis pour tous les
français parce que je ne pense pas moi
personnellement je ne le pense pas et je
pense que c'est ciblées sur un certain
nombre de français oui mais c'est pas
tous les français dont moi j'aimerai
savoir le et puis pensez vous qu'il est
compatible de toujours encourager la
consommation au détriment de
l'investissement parce que si on encore
à la consommation c'est forcément
détriment de l'investissement et est-ce
que c'est compatible avec l'objectif de
sobriété en tout cas ce qu'on essaye de
faire passer comme objectif de sobriété
auprès de nos compatriotes
merci vincent et je voulais être
rassurés tu as été le plus long mais de
très loin
donc pascal savoldelli mais il s'agit
pas d'un goncourt en la matière il ya vu
que c'était pas encouragements président
messieurs les ministres nous avait fait
bilan pouvoir d'achat loi de règlement
et pelles fr et on a une prendre alors
sur le bilan je m'excuse de penser que
vous avez un petit problème d' écoute il
ya la preuve de sincérité sur
le projet de loi de règlement mais ya un
problème de surdité parce que nous avons
nous avons nous avons moi je mets pas en
cause votre légitimité c'est pas la
question
oui on peut pas nous remettre aussi le
bilan ce matin
et pas voir qu'il a quand même été il a
suscité peu d'engouement et il a été en
partie sanctionné donc passons sur cette
question mais quand même
voilà
comme on attrape tout ce que vous
vouliez moi je vais commencer par vous
faire une suggestion allez on y va on
parle franchement vous avez annoncé 10
milliards d'économies nécessaires par
les collectivités territoriales
sur le quinquennat votre président
il est sous tutelle
vous nous dites là dans les résultats
donnés il ya 6,2 milliards de crédits
non utilisés pour le plan de relance
déjà rabaisser déjà là la baille et puis
arrêtez de penser qu'il faut prendre 10
milliards aux collectivités
territoriales ou alors ses pensées
messieurs les ministres parce qu'on va
pas vous distribuer les sujets ça
voudrait dire que la croissance
économique pour vous ne vient que de
l'entreprise bien sûr que l'entreprise
contribue et moi je vais vous demander
de nous faire un travail pas forcément
ce matin mais comment à se retrouver
dans l'hémicycle est ce que le capital
des entreprises à contribuer autant que
les ménages et les administrations
publiques je vous le fais 21 les ménages
ils ont contribué à la croissance trois
fois plus qu'en 2010 9 5 fois plus qu'en
2018 à la croissance économique les
administrations publiques ont multiplié
par 8 leur contribution à la croissance
donc pas forcément une réponse ce matin
mais qu'on regarde voilà si on veut
aller vers une croissance et économique
partagée dernière chose peut-être pour
pas être plus long c'est
j'avoue que moi bon on en a vu des
pelles frd on a même vu une des recettes
prévisibles pour faire des mouvements on
sait pas si c'était par vocation
électorale j'ai regardé recettes de 10,2
milliards supplémentaires entre le dépôt
de projet de loi de finances le 3
novembre 2021 et le 21 décembre donc je
vous avoue je vous interrogeait sur
quand même la sincérité de ces
mouvements là hein on va pas se passe
empêcher cette cette question là voilà
donc dépenses fiscales et politiques
publiques donc la plus précisément à
monsieur le maire j'ai bien noté vous
dit si je me suis trompé et je retirerai
vous avez dit pas de dépenses durable
face à des recettes exceptionnelles
ben moi je vais vous dire par l'on cache
pas par rapport à nous les sénateurs par
rapport à la société française sur la
loi de redressement si on l'appelle fr
et qu'on dit ça ça veut dire qu'à une
face cachée donc falé vie cartes sur
table dit nous dès maintenant papara
bien en amont la loi de finances en nous
disant quelles sont les dépenses durable
de politiques publiques qui ne pourront
pas être pérenne voilà et au moins on
aura un travail d'anticipation en commun
merci j'étais trop l'onction maintenant
comme les autres
donc je rassure tout le monde mais il va
falloir que les suivants rabote encore
un peu plus sa tombe bien on a dit rambo
en ligne et en ligne on peut toujours
dire qu'à un moment donné on l'entend
plus didier
oui bonjour vous m'entendez vous
m'entendez
oui à cet instant oui merci jeu comme
d'habitude je vais très synthétique
trois questions tout d'abord sur la
croissance hélas les plus dignes de
cause yves d'histoire est en train de
connaître un regain d'activité est ce
que ces aléas et voir d'autres d'autres
aléas conjoncturels vont pour et
pourrait limiter la croissance et ainsi
nuire à un équilibre budgétaire de
l'état deuxième question concernant les
collectivités locales
pour le deuxième semestre de l'année en
cours les collectivités locales vont se
retrouver devant une impasse puisque
lorsqu'elles ont adopté leur budget au
printemps dernier et v2 éléments qui
n'avaient pas pris en compte al haouz du
coût de l'énergie et 2
l'augmentation du point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires
donc quels sont les éléments de réponse
que vous pouvez apporter pour pour les
collectivités locales et enfin troisième
remarque qui concerne le rapport de la
cour des comptes sur le budget de l'état
de 2021 que répondez-vous à la cour des
comptes qui dans son rapport
note des atteintes aux principes
d'animaux annualité
disputée dans ce même rapport la cour
des comptes note un manque de pilotage
des dépenses fiscales avec des fonds
certes respecter des succès trop haut
donc elle est jugée rectifie cela est ce
que vous partagez ce point merci
président merci didier christine la
vallée puis michel kahn dette merci à
moi je vais être plus court puisque déjà
beaucoup de choses ont été dites puis
comme le ministre mais coûteux voire
devine mes pensées en allant au delà de
ce que j'ai peut-être pu dire c'est
parfait mais juste pour dire que
l'enthousiasmé effectivement et pas
forcément partagé parce que on a chuté
beaucoup plus fort donc heureusement
qu'on est remonté un peu plus fort que
les autres sinon notre situation à ce
serait beaucoup plus catastrophique je
vais me reposer une question que j'ai
déjà posé on fait vrai l'année dernière
pour laquelle je n'avais pas eu de
réponse donc jeu j'aimerais savoir en
fait où sont les mesures d'économies
structurelles qui vont nous permettre de
baisser le déficit pour atteindre 5% en
2023 et 3% en 2027 puisque je n'en vois
pas et je voudrais juste citer la
commission européenne dans son analyse
du pnr de la france qui dit l'analyse de
la commission fait apparaître des
risques élevés pour la soutenabilité de
la dette à moyen terme en tant que tel
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de rendre un
quelconque commencement au remboursement
de la dette on se félicite mais quand le
pib augmente la le ratio diminue et
j'aurais juste une autre marque un peu
factuel mais en audition du 30 mars
j'avais remarqué que c'était bizarre
dans le décret d'avancé de venir réduire
les programmes du 174 notamment sur les
crédits ma prime rénové bonus je
constate que là vous l'airé augmenté sur
ces deux dispositifs et enfin juste une
petite question un peu technique mais
vous nous avez parlé des contrats
d'énergie renouvelable qui représente un
budget conséquent un plus de 8 milliards
5 vous avez évoqué certains contrats
savoir ceux qui sont aux compléments de
rémunération pour lesquelles vous venez
cap est ce que les producteurs doivent
remettre mais il ya tous les anciens
contrats qui ont été signés dans
l'ancien régime qui explique la majorité
des charges qui sont constatés vous ne
fait pas état d'une diminution des coûts
de ses charges de service public est ce
à dire que vous attendez la délibération
de la commission de régulation qui doit
intervenir au mois de juillet avec vous
nous présenter un amendement au moment
de l'étude du texte en séance ce qui
permettra de dégager des ressources qui
pourront être affectés au remboursement
de la dette
merci christine michel canévet dans un
art de synthèse qui le 4 6 merci
monsieur le président le groupe de
l'union centriste voudrais tout d'abord
vous féliciter et messieurs les
ministres pour la charge qui vous
incombe de piloter bercy et les finances
publiques et la tâche sera ardue car la
situation est quand même
particulièrement préoccupante
alors il ya tout d'abord effectivement
le niveau du déficit comme vincent
delerm moi je regrette qu'on passe très
peu de temps sur la loi de règlement et
pourtant c'est important parce que on
termine l'exercice avec un déficit
public de 177 milliards ce qui est tout
à fait considérable en tout cas bien
d'autres ce sera au-dessus de la moyenne
observée
durant la décennie précédente et un
encours de dette
une émission de dette cette année de 185
milliards qui est aussi considérable
alors la baisse des impôts notre groupe
qui est tout à fait favorable à
condition que l'on permette quand même
l'autonomie fiscale et budgétaire des
collectivités territoriales cela a été
dit tout à l'heure
des charges supplémentaires vont arriver
il faut en tenir compte et puis à
condition aussi que l'envers retour à
l'équilibré des finances publiques ce
qui est extrêmement important pour nous
et donc on sera attentif à ce sujet
alors nous examinons aussi la loi de
finances rectificative
nous partageons l'essentiel des
désorientations
comme vincent delerm moi j'ai la
préoccupation de savoir comment pour
france compétences les choses dans le
passé puisqu'il ya une nette de 2
milliards il ya déficit de 5 milliards
il ya des économies de 800 millions donc
on n'y sera pas tout à fait comme en
france compétences va-t-il équilibrer
ses comptes et puis pour ce qui concerne
la dignité inflation nous partageons
totalement l'idée qu'il faut aider ceux
qui vont au travail et ceux qui sont en
formation mais quand vous avez dit tout
est là monsieur lumineuse chaque euro
compte moi je crois qu'il faudrait qu'on
arrête très rapidement l'aide
généralisée parce que il n'y a aucune
raison de continuer à donner une
subvention pour tout ce qui va avec
leurs quatre cas tout le reste suivait
en vacances en normandie en bretagne ou
dans le sud de la france et comme chaque
euro compte il importe d'arrêter ce
dispositif le plus rapidement possible
pour que un dispositif ciblé sur ceux
qui en ont besoin et sur ceux qui
travaillent soient rapidement mises en
oeuvre
mais toit qui coule et vous avez encore
des chocolats non mais ne vous inquiétez
pas nous reverrons les ministres voilà
un 1-1 séances en particulier puis voilà
nous aurons d'autres occasions
mais c'est simplement parce que enfin
dans quelques mois on vous a pas vu donc
tout d'un coup
bon voilà alors feat je vais me faire
part de ton fils dominati puis isabelle
briquet se prépare en ligne
sur ministre sur le fond je dirais ya
peu d'emballement parce que vous faites
un exercice difficile et que l'on
connaît à chaque début de quinquennat en
réalité depuis que je suis dans cette
maison à chaque fois des engagements
étaient pris et jamais respecté en fin
de quinquennat parce que l'exercice est
très difficile l'originalité monsieur le
ministre c'est que vous direz à percy et
c'est la première fois qu'un ministre
des finances refait cet exercice je
dirais après un bilan qui il faut bien
reconnaître des objectifs n'ont pas été
tenues au cours du précédent quinquennat
il ya toujours un aléa on l'a connue
avec nicolas sarkozy avec françois
hollande
avec jacques chirac donc c'est un
exercice qui sur le fond maintenant a
perdu un peu d'éclat parce que
d'habitude normalement il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de communication et on sait
très bien que vous ne tiendrez pas ces
chiffres que vous n'obtiendrez pas
l'objectif que ce soit sur la dette ou
sur le déficit alors moi mais deux
questions sont simples la première vous
avez palais de justice la justice est ce
qu'il y aura une revalorisation des
barèmes notamment de l'impôt sur le
revenu bien évidemment mais pour les
entreprises des plafonds de tout ce qui
concerne la défiscalisation partir du
moment où on dit on va revaloriser pour
les agents de l'état et pour les
retraités ce que l'on va remonter les
barèmes de bercy puisque généralement la
justice c'est que sur les barèmes on
traîne un peu ça c'est la première
question la deuxième c'est que il y
avait un objectif lors du dernier plan
quinquennal c'était la suppression
d'emplois publics moitié collectivités
locales moitié état il en a rien été
heureusement j'ai vu qu'il y avait une
certaine rigueur et sur ce plan là moi
je vous félicite je suis plutôt content
d'apprendre que il n'ya pas lui il ya eu
une légère réduction des emplois publics
je voudrais savoir ce qu'il en est
réellement parce qu'il ya pratiquement
peu de communication sur les cinq ans
qui viennent sur ce sujet là et c'est
pourtant un critère assez déterminant
merci philippe isabelle briquet puis
d'années l'ouvrier
isobel en ligne
très bien
le petit point il y aura une remarque
pour le projet de loi de règlement que
dans dans sa représentation ne fasse
rien un satisfécit fin de la part du
gouvernement or l'exécution du boucher
un des
particuliers avec des exercices de vin
bouleversé en dossier par la crise
sanitaire et de nombreux indicateurs se
trouve amélioré son temps s'assoit rice
véritablement
succès des politiques menées par
ailleurs la cour des comptes ne pas dire
l'enthousiasmé chez non plus sur le bel
effet à un petit point cela a déjà été
évoqué mais je souhaite revenir sur un
article de ce plfr qui pour moi est
symbolique d'une une certaine politique
mais gare aux services publics la
suppression de la contribution à
l'audiovisuel unique présentée comme une
illusion de pouvoir d'achat bien
évidemment la question financement
et les éléments avancés dont se paie les
verts sont loin de garantir l'accès
[Musique]
et de qualité dont je souhaiterais
savoir quelles mesures concrètes peuvent
être déployées à cette fin et enfin
jeunes est un petit point d' alerte cela
a été dit au ciné sont les collectivités
de la situation financière s'est
vraiment
l'augmentation du coût de l'énergie et
des matières premières et alors que dix
milliards et demi sont annoncés sur les
connectivités
soutien
merci isabelle daniel brillet puis
sylvie vermeillet en ligne merci
monsieur le président messieurs des
ministres d'abord une observation sur le
projet de règlement du budget au plus
tôt une proposition je souhaiterais que
le but les verts ne couvre plus pas que
7% des dépenses mais l'ensemble
lorsqu'on affiche les ambitions aussi
importante que la fée la première
ministre sur la transition écologique il
est nécessaire d'avoir les outils de
pilotage et j'ajoute que les dépenses
aujourd'hui jugée favorable sur ces 7 %
ne le sont qu'en comparaison du de
l'existant préalable il conviendrait de
les référer également à la trajectoire
nécessaires pour que notre pays tienne
ses engagements internationaux et pas
seulement à l'exercice précédent
maintenant sur le sur le plfr j'ai
d'abord une question yat-il f comme le
dit michel edouard leclerc des
profiteurs de crise selon l'insee les
taux de marge dans les domaines de
l'énergie de l'eau des déchets est passé
de 61 74 % de 39 à 47 % pour les
transports ces deux secteurs sont en
amont des chaînes de valeur et il
contribue largement à amplifier
l'inflation une remarque monsieur le
ministre l'accélération ça n'est pas
d'accélération de la transition
écologique qui est très coûteuse pour
l'inflation c'est plutôt l'accélération
de la crise climatique qui est le
facteur de l'inflation et la transition
écologique et une réponse indispensable
face à cette accélération de la crise
climatique
enfin une remarque sur les mesures de
revalorisation anticipé des pensions les
soutiens tout ça est absolument
indispensable
insuffisant mais indispensable au fond
lorsque vous êtes un salariés modestes
ou pauvres c'est d'abord par le salaire
que les mesures d'amélioration du
pouvoir d'achat doivent passer et pas
par des mesures ponctuelles
je me permets d'insister et posé une
question combien de salariés n'ont pas
bénéficié de la prime macron je ne parle
pas de ceux qui en bénéficient mais
combien n'ont pas bénéficié
nous créons une inégalité l'inflation
touche tous les salariés tous les foyers
et beaucoup de salariés ne bénéficieront
pas parce que leur entreprise ne pourra
pas ou ne voudra pas puisque c'est à
leur bon vouloir et je termine par une
proposition consensuelle puisque j'ai
entendu l'appel au consensus
par madame la première ministre ma
proposition consensuelle est la suivante
12 milliards sont réservés en gros à la
nationalisation recapitalisation d'edf
peut-être face à l'obligation de faire
face aux coûts à 10o d'aidé aux pme
sujet messieurs les ministres que ces 12
milliards soit totalement investi dans
le renouvelable où ils seront mieux
utilisés pour lutter pour notre
indépendance nous engagements
climatiques et la résilience des
territoires et je suis certain d'avoir
l'adhésion de l'ensemble des membres de
la commission sur un tel objectif
notre nom jurés pas quand même daniel
bon bienvenus
sylvie vermeillet donc en ligne puis
vincent segouin qui clôturera les
questions
merci monsieur le président bonjour
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues j'aurai une question
concernant l'impôt
monsieur bruno le maire vous avez
exposé des notions de justice et
d'équité
je pense que les crises que nous
traversons qui génère de l'inflation
génère des dépenses supplémentaires pour
nos concitoyens qui ont les revenus les
plus faibles et par ailleurs certaines
grandes sociétés pétrolières par exemple
réalisent des profits tout à fait
exceptionnel est ce que vous vous
autorisez malgré tout à réfléchir à une
taxation temporaire de la même manière
que les efforts de l'état en faveur des
plus démunis serait temporaire est ce
qu'on ne peut pas s'autoriser à
réfléchir à une taxation temporaire pour
ses grandes entreprises qui réalisent
des bénéfices absolument conséquent en
voyant les résultats publiés des premier
et deuxième trimestres je pensais total
energy évidemment mais à d'autres
également
je le dis parce que bien sûr
l'italie et le royaume uni ils y ont
réfléchi mais effectivement c'est que ce
sont des pays producteurs donc c'était
assez évident
néanmoins d'autres pays européens y
réfléchisse ou le met en place la
hongrie la roumanie l'espagne
l'allemagne même d'allemagne donc est-ce
que c'est malgré tout pas une piste à
creuser dans un souci d'équité parce que
quel que soit le niveau de notre dette
je trouve correct que l'état regarde les
super profits là où il va accepter de
dépenser beaucoup d'argent pour venir en
aide à ceux qui en ont le plus besoin et
qu'il ya deuxième question quelle est la
déclinaison concrète
de la revalorisation du point d'indicé
pour les collectivités territoriales
je vous remercie merci sylvie vincent
segouin
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
lorsque nous visitons les entreprises
sommes sidérés et entendre le manque
d'emploi et même cette recrudescence de
d'emploi libre
ma question c'est simple vous vous
admettez que
la croissance créer des recettes
exceptionnelles qui qui ne sont pas
utilisés dans les comptes de l'état donc
l'emploi le travail et la soumission
d'après ce que l'on détermine
donc ça c'est plutôt une bonne chose par
contre donc les mesures noël le pont à
ses travailleurs ça c'est encore une
bonne chose à mon goût mais en même
temps on reste toujours dans la
politique et en même temps on augmente
les minima sociaux
nous sommes à un taux de chômage de 7,3
pour cent lorsque tous les pays de la
zone euro ce pays bas presque trois et
demi 4 %
je vois pas dans dans la description de
votre politique de mesures envers cette
diminution du taux de chômage je vois
pas de mesures pour inciter les
personnes à travailler et donc créer des
recettes nouvelles pour les entreprises
qui sont bénéficiaires à l'état voilà
donc ça me surprend et j'aimerais vous
entendre sur le sujet pour savoir ce
qu'il et comment vous voyez les choses
pour l'avenir
merci vincent nous avons terminé les
questions je vais donner la parole au
ministre le maire en vous indiquant
qu'il sera obligé à l'issue de sa prise
de parole de nous quitter parce qu'il a
d'autres d'autres rendez vous monsieur
le ministre merci de votre compréhension
monsieur le président et pardon
l'avancent dois vous quitter pour
rejoindre une autre réunion jérôme
bascher sur
le pib il s'agit pas de pousser des
cocoricos c'est vrai que la france a
subi lourdement le coc vide mais elle
s'est redressée plus rapidement que les
autres ce qui mérite malgré tout d'être
salués c'est pas la politique du
gouvernement c'est ce qu'ont fait les
entreprises et les salariés nous sommes
le premier pays de la zone euro avoir
retrouvé son niveau d'activité d'avant
crise et ça je pense que ça témoigne
d'une chaussée du dynamisme et de la
solidité d'économie française moi je ne
comprends jamais pourquoi faut toujours
qu'on accable les français les salariés
les entreprises de tous les maux je dis
pas ça pour la politique du gouvernement
je dis ça pour tous ceux qui sont
retroussé les manches ont gardé leur
entreprise ouverte qu'on refusait de
fermer des salariés qui sont allés
travailler les travers de la deuxième
mine qui sont quand même allés aux
caisses des supermarchés pour faire leur
boulot et c'est tous ces gens là qu'ils
ont permis de rebondir vite donc que la
france soit le premier pays à rebondir
aussi rapidement et retrouver son niveau
de croissance d'avant crise je pense que
ça mérite
une fierté nationale que je ne dépose
pas une fois encore sur la tête du
gouvernement mais sur la tête de chaque
français qui travaille
ensuite sur
l'inflation oui nous la maîtrisons mieux
que les autres d'un fait le taux
d'inflation le plus faible de la zone
euro
c'est le taux français
donc nous avons tenu compte des alertes
effectivement du sénat d'un certain
nombre d'économistes pour prendre
rapidement des mesures
ensuite sur les mesures d'offres je vous
rassure notre politique reste une
politique d'offres tout ce qui est fait
sa prime d'activité sur la baisse des
impôts de production sur la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires va effectivement dans ce
sens là et je vous rejoins totalement
vous comme beaucoup d'autres sénateurs
qui disent que le premier problème
aujourd'hui des entreprises c'est la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est le
premier problème des entreprises quand
on regarde la distribution l'industrie
agroalimentaire le bâtiment les travaux
publics j'étais aux herbiers en vendée
il ya pas très longtemps vous voyez sur
toutes les façades des entreprises des
appels à l'emploi donc il faut
impérativement qu'on se concentre là
dessus ça doit passer par cette
politique de l'offre là je vous rejoins
sur ce point et certainement aussi par
l'application de la réforme d'assurance
chômage qui permet d'inciter au retour à
l'emploi
roger karoutchi est effectivement parler
salaire bien entendu c'est dire ce qu
ont parfaitement compris des secteurs
d'activité l'hôtellerie la restauration
ils ont compris que s'il y avait pas une
forte augmentation des salaires il
n'arriverait plus à faire tourner leurs
restaurants et des hôtels c'est déjà
très difficile et sont allés plus loin
parce que je pense que le salaire ne
suffit pas en aménageant les horaires de
travail parce que c'est bien facile de
dire voilà les jeunes veulent plus
bosser je pense que c'est complètement
faux je pense simplement qu'ils
attendent une autre organisation de leur
travail et qu'ils ont raison ils ont
raison et c'est à nous d'apporter des
réponses aussi aux attentes de la
société et notamment aux attentes des
plus jeunes dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie la restauration comme dans
d'autres secteurs
roger karoutchi je partage votre
prudence je pose un scénario central et
je reconnais bien volontiers que
notamment la guerre en ukraine les
incertitudes sur les approvisionnements
énergétiques et l'attitude de la lumière
poutine sont les choses clairement
menace ce scénario je vais pas vous dire
mon scénario il est sûr et certain je
vous le garantie sur facture non s'il ya
bien une chose que j'ai apprise au cours
du dernier quinquennat c'est la prudence
et l'humidité dans les prévisions donc
nous devons faire un scénario central il
est là je pense qu'il est raisonnable
mais je ne peux pas exclure les
scénarios que vous avez indiquée ça rend
d'autant plus nécessaire de tenir une
ligne qui soit claire sur les
fondamentaux
rétablissement des finances publiques
politique de l'offre poursuite des
réformes structurelles notamment la
réforme des retraites
or en chômage je pense que ce cadre là
il a un mérite c'est que quelle que soit
la tempête ça permet de savoir où on va
et comment est-ce que le pays s'en
sortira au bout du compte sur les cils
commercial c'est vrai que le chiffre
n'est pas bon j'ai pas le contester mais
enfin je constate que pour la première
fois depuis des décennies
l'allemagne a un déficit commercial donc
ça montre le bide allemagne c'est
vraiment unique en son genre
c'est la première fois que l'allemagne
accuse un déficit commercial alors que
ça a été sa puissance économique reposer
là dessus comme vous le savez tous ça
montre à quel point nous sommes
confrontés à des défis qui sont lourds
vincent delahaye gabriel vous répondra
sur la loi de règlement france compétent
je partage la nécessité de regarder de
près la manière dont sont organisés et
dépenser les crédits quand on parle de
pouvoir d'achat je partage votre constat
il n'est pas du tout le même en fonction
du niveau de revenu des français parlons
d'enfoncer les portes ouvertes ce que je
me garde de trop avancé sur les chiffres
globaux donnée par l'insee et qui
montrent que nous protégeons bien le
pouvoir d'achat des français mais c'est
une moyenne et dans cette moyenne il ya
effectivement de vraies disparités c'est
la raison pour laquelle il me paraît
indispensable de cibler les dispositifs
et je revendique le choix qui est fait
sur les carburants plutôt que de
dépenser près d'un milliard d'euros par
mois par mois pour protéger tous les
français face à l'augmentation des
carburants je préfère que nous
basculions à partir du 1er octobre vers
un dispositif plus ciblé sur ceux qui en
ont réellement besoin
pascal salvo dénis d'abord je vous
rassure je ne suis sous tutelle de
personnes je suis sous l'autorité du
président de la république c'est un tout
petit peu différent ensuite les chiffres
que vous avez donné les chiffres que
vous avez donnée
ce sont les bons et moi je suis là pour
appliquer justement le projet du
président de la république 40 milliards
d'euros d'économies 20 sur l'état 10 sur
les retraites dit sur les collectivités
locales il faut que nous y travaillons
ensemble il ya certaines collectivités
quand une bonne surprise elle aussi en
matière de recettes et puis vous avez
d'autres collectivités qui sont en
situation beaucoup plus difficile
notamment les plus petites d'entre elles
notamment les communes rurales je
connais bien dans mon département de
l'eure donc moi je vous propose que nous
travaillons ensemble sur ce sujet est
d'ailleurs de manière plus générale à
tous ceux qui disent qu'il faut
effectivement réduire certaines dépenses
structurelles je dis oui et je propose
qu'il y ait un travail collectif entre
le gouvernement les députés les
sénateurs pour que avant en amont et là
je rejoins votre proposition avant le
plf 2023 plutôt que 15 jours avant se
précipitent pour dire tiens revoilà les
économies possibles nous regardions
ensemble les économies qui sont
possibles et souhaitables
c'est effectivement une proposition qui
un caractère révolutionnaire mais qui me
paraît indispensable dans les
circonstances actuelles
didier rambaud je ne reviens pas sur la
croissance à 2,5 g 10 toutes les
incertitudes qui entourent ce chiffre
mais se pense que c'est un chiffre qui
rejoint le consensus actuel de beaucoup
de prévisionnistes
christine lagarde ces mesures
d'économies structurelles je fais cette
proposition je pense qu'elle est
absolument indispensable ensuite comment
est-ce que nous atteindrons de 3% de
déficit qui reste en objectifs
structurels pour 2027 par le plein
emploi que nous n'avons pas atteint
depuis un demi siècle et on on sous
estime les vertus du plein emploi sont
des vertus politiques des vertus
économiques des vertus sociales des
vertus de confiance en soi pour le
peuple français donc pour moi c'est
l'objectif numéro un ensuite des
réformes de structure est présent dans
le public était très clair informe des
retraites appliquées en 2023 et et 2023
et la réduction des dépenses sur
laquelle je propose que nous travaillons
ensemble
michel canevet j'ai répondu sur france
compétences mais le point et bien
notez également sur l'aide généralisée
au carburant qui ne me paraît pas
aujourd'hui la meilleure solution et
photos basculions vers cette aide plus
ciblées
philippe dominati donc les musiques de
dette et de déficit je vous dis pour
tout faire pour les retenir c'est c'est
ma responsabilité
s'agissant la revalorisation des barèmes
d'impôts sur le revenu à lui est
évidemment indispensable pour éviter que
vous ayez des ménages qui bascule dans
la position est contraire à notre
politique cela sera fait dans le projet
de loi de finances 2010 23 pour les
revenus 2022 isabelle briquet la
question sur la sape et gabriel vous y
répondre à daniel gremillet sur la prime
macron elle a touché 5 millions de
salariés pour 500 euros en moyenne donc
ce n'est pas négligeable il reste
effectivement qu'un de nos salariés qui
par définition ne sont pas touchés donc
je ne saurais trop inciter les
entreprises à utiliser les instruments
qui sont mis à leur disposition et on a
des dizaines de milliers d'entreprises
dont des dizaines de milliers de cas
différents vous avez d'entreprises qui
bénéficient de cette crise parce qu'elle
est sur un secteur d'activité qui est
profitable ça peut être par exemple les
transports moi je souhaite que ces
entreprises là augmente les salaires
quand elles le peuvent elle peut se
projeter sur le long terme elles peuvent
augmenter les salaires beaucoup le font
d'ailleurs et je les en remercie
il ya d'autres plus petites entreprises
le patron vous dis moi j'aimerais bien
augmenter mes salariés mais je peux pas
menacer la vie de mon entreprise que si
un retournement de conjoncture
tel que le prévoit roger karoutchi en
2023 ben je serai pas bien si j'ai
augmenté mes salaires jeudi je comprends
je comprends parfaitement ce
raisonnement et jeudi dans ce cas-là
utiliser la prime parce que là vous ne
menaçait pas la survie d'autres
entreprises en cas de retournement de
conjoncture
et enfin je dis à toutes les entreprises
l'intéressement et la participation
c'est vraiment une manière de
récompenser vos salariés on a largement
augmenté le nombre de salariés qui sont
couverts mais ce n'est pas encore
satisfaisant on a simplifié le
dispositif utilisé le
civil est relayée est pas bon sur les
profiteurs de crise bien entendu nous
voulons contrôler et sanctionner nous
mettons en place deux instruments
d'abord des contrôles de la dgccrf qui
vont être renforcés sur ce sujet
spécifique et une mission de l'idf à
laquelle je souhaite associer les
députés les sénateurs et le monde
agricole pour nous assurer que le seuil
de revente à perte et et 10% au-dessus
des 10% de succès de revente à plâtre
mais dans la poche des producteurs et ne
disparaissent pas justement dans la
poche de profiteurs donc je vous propose
de participer à cette mission de
l'inspection générale des finances qui
portera sur l'application du seuil de
revente à perte et de la rémunération
des producteurs agricoles auxquels je
suis évidemment profondément attaché
sylvie vermeillet moi je souhaite que
les entreprises qui le peuvent et qui
font des profits dans ces périodes
difficiles le redistribue très
concrètement la poche des françaises je
préfère que des entreprises fassent des
remises à la pompe plutôt que de prendre
une taxe sur elle je préfère vous savez
dans la poche des français plutôt que
dans la poche du trésor public mais il
faut que ce soit suffisant
et donc nous ferons les comptes à la fin
de l'année pour nous assurer que toutes
les entreprises qui ont fait des profits
très important pendant cette période de
pic inflationniste ou bien redistribuer
une partie directement aux français ça
vaut pour les entreprises énergétiques
ça vaut pour les entreprises de
transport maritime cma-cgm a déjà fait
un effort je salue ça vaut pour les
banques avec les frais bancaires ça vaut
pour les assurances ça vaut pour tous
les secteurs d'activités sur lesquels
nous pourrions avoir des marges de
manoeuvre et nous ferons les comptes à
la fin de l'année questions de vincent
second qui la dernière concernait mon
camarade et ami et rural
merci merci monsieur le ministre le
maire
pour cette audition nous vous libérons
je vais donner la parole à gabriel attal
et en même temps demandé à ma collègue
christine lagarde bien vouloir me
supplée à la présidence de la commission
vous n'êtes vous n'y perdrez pas
c'est ça
tu t'étais déjà préparé
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
vous et rien qu'à vous
merci madame la vice présidente ravie
d'incarner avec vous l'équipe b pour la
fin de cette édition je vais d'abord
répondre à quelques sud oui c'est ça il
ya l'équipe à des sénateurs qui je vais
je vais d'abord répondre à quelques
questions transversales qui ont été
évoquées par plusieurs d'entre vous
avant de venir sur les interventions
plus particulière sur des points plus
particulier plusieurs d'entre vous sont
revenus sur la question des reports de
crédits effectivement nous avons alors
même que depuis 2007 nous avions fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour en avoir
beaucoup moins nous avons une
augmentation très forte des reports de
crédits d'une année sur l'autre entre
2020 et 2021 et entre 2021 et 2022 et je
pense que chacun peut le comprendre du
fait de la situation sanitaire de la
crise ukrainienne il ya un certain
nombre d'aléas qui nous ont amenés à
prévoir un certain nombre de crédits qui
ont ensuite été reportée je vous donne
deux exemples sur 2020 les crédits non
consommés en fin d'année sur le budget
général c'était 37,5 milliards d'euros
est principalement lié aux crédits non
consommés de la mission plan d'urgence
face à la crise sanitaire
28,8 milliards d'euros on avait oui il y
avait une marge dans un contexte encore
une fois de survenue d'une crise
historique et il vaut parfois mieux
prendre de la marge que se retrouvaient
en incapacité de payer en l'occurrence
la déteste
ou des dispositifs de soutien à
l'économie dans le contexte de crise en
2021 crédits non consommés ont baissé
puisque c'était 24 6 milliards d'euros
et là il y avait à la fois la mission
que les sanitaires et le plan de relance
que vous savez que le plan de relance
est prévu pour se déployer sur deux ans
et donc il ya eu là aussi là aussi des
reports sur ensuite la question de la
dette il ya eu plusieurs questions
notamment monsieur de l'oeil monsieur
ben asher sur la charge de la dette
monsieur de la s et es sur la part de la
dette indexée sur l'inflation il me
semble et monsieur ben asher sur
l'impact de la hausse de la charge de la
dette sur le post charge de la dette
dans les principaux postes budgétaires
de l'état donc nous ouvrons 11 milliards
886 millions très exactement dans ce plr
sur la charge de la dette sur la mission
engagement financier de l'état et c'est
à la fois l'effet de la hausse des taux
et l'effet de la hausse de l'inflation
puisque effectivement une partie de
notre dette est indexé sur l'inflation
est d'ailleurs pas simplement sur
l'inflation française mais sur
l'inflation monde il me semble
moyenne europe pardon ce qui fait que
nous avons un impact plus important que
c'était la seule inflation france donc
sur ce total la charge d'indexation un
peindrai 15 6 milliards d'euros en 2022
soit 30% du total de la charge de la
dette et en particulier 10,8 milliards
d'euros de plus que le sous jacent de la
haye les fics était de 4,9 milliards
d'euros on peut ainsi estimer que plus
de 90% de l'impact à la hausse de la
charge de la dette vis-à-vis de la loi
de finances initiale procède d'urso de
la charge d'indexation et donc
directement de l'inflation sur la
question de monsieur ben asher sur la
charge de la dette donc loi de finances
initiale 22 milliards prévus
38 milliards 7 en plus non non pardon
non loi de finances initiale c'était
38,7 milliards de prévu en loi de
finances initiale 2022 ont elles
augmenté de 11,9 milliards donc ça fait
51 milliards jusque là on est d'accord
jusque là on est d'accord le budget de
la défense effectivement dans la lfc 22
c 49 milliards d'euros donc oui
effectivement le poste charge de la
déesse de la dette passe au dessus il
reste en dessous de l'éducation
nationale il me semble mais il passe
au dessus ce qui il passe haute ça c'est
pas sur eux
ce qui montre deux choses 1 ce qui
montre deux choses 1 la nécessité de
ce qui montre deux choses 1 la nécessité
de réduire nos déficits de stabiliser
puis de réduire notre dette et deux de
continuer à faire augmenter le budget de
la défense conformément à la loi de
programmation militaire et aux travaux
que nous sommes en train de mener ces
deux engagements seront évidemment tenu
par le gouvernement il y avait ensuite
un bloc important sur les collectivités
locales avec plusieurs interventions
d'entre d'entre vous
avec deux questions principales comment
avec deux
laissez le ministre finir et ensuite
offrons nos commentaires entre nous
jamais pouvoir y arriver
j'avais deux questions principales sur
sur les collectivités locales il me
semble c'est à la fois l'impact de la
hausse décidée du point d indice de 3 5%
pour le budget des collectivités
locales et puis la participation des
collectivités locales à notre objectif
je crois collectif de maîtrise de la
progression des dépenses publiques sur
le premier point la hausse de 3 5% du
point d'indicé qui était je crois
convenons tous nécessaires pour garantir
le pouvoir d'achat de nos fonctionnaires
dans un contexte d'inflation très
importante représente un coût pour les
collectivités de 1 milliard d'euros en
2022 et de 2,1 milliards d'euros en
année pleine donc à compter de 2023 il
me semble important dans le contexte
d'inflation
qui à la fois un impact sur des charges
pour les collectivités locales mais
aussi un impact indirect avec la hausse
du point que nous décidons pour
compenser l'inflation de regarder aussi
l'impact sur les recettes des
collectivités locales je me suis fait
communiquer hier le détail des recettes
sur les cinq premiers mois de l'année
2022 et les recettes réelles de
fonctionnement sont en progression de
4,8 milliards d'euros par rapport aux
cinq premiers mois de 2000 21 jeux
postale a comme on dit on verra à la fin
de l'année on aura par ailleurs un grand
moments de discussion sur le budget des
collectivités locales est sur la
trajectoire mais il me semble important
de souligner qu'il ya une augmentation
très forte des recettes qui est
constatée sur les cinq premiers mois de
l'année 2022 oui il ya un effet de
l'inflation mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que on peut parler on peut parler
de on peut parler de l'effet de
l'inflation en charge pour les
collectivités est évidemment le fait et
c'est une réalité mais il faut aussi
regarder l'inflation en recettes ce
qu'elle produit en recettes pour les
collectivités locales en l'occurrence
sur les cinq premiers mois de l'année en
hausse de 4,8 milliards d'euros des
recettes réelles de fonctionnement des
collectivités par rapport à la même
période en 2021 il me semble important
de le souligner est sûr maintenant les
fameux 10 milliards que vous avez
rappelé je veux vraiment être très clair
quand le président de la république
s'est exprimé dans le cadre de l'expo de
la campagne il a simplement indiqué que
nous avions collectivement un objectif
de maîtrise de la progression des
dépenses publiques et que nous estimions
dans le cadre du cadrage financier qui a
été présenté dans le cadre de la
campagne que les collectivités pouvaient
y participer de l'ordre de 10 milliards
d'euros est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
s'agit de dire que comme entre 2014 et
2017 nous prévoyons une baisse des
ressources des collectivités locales je
ne crois pas du tout ce n'est pas du
tout l'esprit de ce que le président de
la république a dit donc les recettes
comme les dépenses des collectivités
locales vont continuer de progresser
dans le quinquennat ce que le président
de la république a dit ce sur quoi il
s'est engagé dans le cadre d'un cadrage
financier de sa campagne c'est que nous
nous accordions sur un rythme de
progression des dépenses dans le
quinquennat qui s'ouvre il ya eu un
outil qui a été utilisé dans le
quinquennat qui s'achève celui des
contrats de cahors sur la progression
des dépenses de fonctionnement
on verra quel outil pourra être utilisée
c'est un vrai nécessaire et beau débat
que nous aurons dans le cadre du projet
de loi de finances pour 2023 sur la
question du budget des collectivités
locales et nous aurons ce débat sans
tabou évidemment je vais ensuite sur les
autres sujets il n'y a pas de votre sur
les autres sujets qui ont été abordés
plusieurs d'entre vous notamment
monsieur karoutchi madame briquet on ré
abordé le sujet de la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public et de son impact
pour les sociétés moi je vais vous dire
là non plus je n'ai pas de tabou j'en ai
très peu mais je n'ai pas de tabou sur
ce point non plus sur ce qu'on peut
faire pour garantir l'indépendance enfin
d'abord pour moi l'indépendance me
semble assez nettement garantie par la
loi léotard et par la réglementation
actuelle et par les autorités actuelles
vous abordiez la question d'une
commission enfin moi j'ai rien contre
les commissions encore que je trouve
qu'on a souvent réflexe de créer une
commission à chaque fois qu'il ya une
réforme ou un problème est que moi j'ai
toujours été plutôt favorable à regarder
ce qu'on pouvait faire avec avec les
institutions existantes qu'en
l'occurrence l'art comme autorité
indépendante et quand même saisi pour
examiner les contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens que nous signons avec les
sociétés de jeux visuels public
que par ailleurs elle remet ce karoutchi
soyez sages seul le ministre à la parole
et j'y vois comme j'y vois un bizutage
de mon collègue karoutchi des
hauts-de-seine puisque nous nous
connaissons bien nous sommes élus nous
sommes élus nous sommes élus du même
département avec vous d'ailleurs madame
lagarde est par ailleurs l'art comme
remis un avis sur le projet de loi de
finances donc enfin et par ailleurs je
le dis quand même quand on parle de
commission qui travaille en indépendance
sur le budget de l'audiovisuel public il
me semble que les commissions
parlementaires ce soit la commission des
finances où les commissions des affaires
culturelles travaille en indépendance et
sont à même de donner leur avis sur le
budget de l'audiovisuel public
d'ailleurs elle le vote donc moi j'ai
pas de encore une fois on aura un débat
dans le cadre du plfr probablement dans
le plf sur sur ce sujet là j'ai pas de
tabou mais rajouter une commission qui
viendrait se substituer à l'art comme et
aux commissions parlementaires me semble
pas tout à fait nécessaire moi je suis
attaché aux institutions et aux rôles
aussi des parlementaires pour remettre
des avis mais plus que ça pour prendre
des décisions
évidemment qu'ils sont nécessaires je
passe peut-être rapidement monsieur de
lait sur les frais protocolaire je vous
renvoie à la documentation annexe et au
plf et aux rapports annuels de
performance par exemple jaune consacré
aux personnels affectés dans les
cabinets ministériels souvent très
commenté la documentation permettra je
pense de faire une analyse sur la
typologie de dépenses que vous évoquez
notamment sur la question des
déplacements mais je le dis tout net si
on peut et mon équipe peut vous
permettre de deux ans va dire d'avoir
une appréhension une vision que le club
plus transversale sur les postes de
dépenses que vous évoquez évidemment
totalement d'accord pour le faire et
elle sera à votre disposition sur france
compétences bruno le maire s'est exprimé
mais je veux dire que le chiffre qui a
été évoqué un moment dans l'audition de
cinq milliards d'euros de déficit en 22
est un peu surestimé que nous tablons
sur 4,6 milliards d'euros dont 2,6
milliards d'euros financée par emprunt
et 2 milliards d'euros par subvention
exceptionnelle de l'état ce sont les 2
milliards d'euros de crédits qui sont
ouverts dans le plfr c'est un déficit
qui est
notamment et principalement lié à la
très forte hausse des dépenses sur
l'apprentissage c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle que nous ayons une politique
d'apprentissage très dynamique mais ça
ne nous empêche pas de regarder comment
faire des économies rationaliser un
certain nombre de dépenses et nous avons
d'ores et déjà demandé au cfa de
rationaliser leurs coûts de
fonctionnement avec un objectif d'au
moins 10% d'ici 2023
ce qui représente 0,7 0,8 milliard
d'euros d'économies et d'efficience à
terme et nous réfléchissons à de
nouvelles mesures de maîtrise des
dépenses comme sur l'ensemble du champ
des politiques de l'emploi là aussi nous
aurons le débat en plf
2023 monsieur rambo a posé une question
sur les dépenses fiscales moi je veux
rappeler que sur le précédent
quinquennat nous avons fait un programme
d'évaluation et de bornage sur le sujet
que nous avons supprimé je crois que
c'était une soixantaine de dépenses
fiscales
inefficiente que nous avons conduit à
bien quelques gros chantiers notamment
celui sur le pinel et que nous avons
amélioré la documentation budgétaire
avec notamment le budget vert mais je
crois qu'il ne suffit pas de multiplier
les obligations déclaratives pour avoir
un chiffre mais ce don de nous avons le
plus besoin c'est une vraie évaluation
qualitative
dispositif pour les améliorer je pense
que c'est un débat que nous aurons là
aussi dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques et
nous proposerons là aussi des mesures
pour une bonne gestion des dépenses
fiscales et je redis que notre volonté
constante ça a toujours été 2 entre
guillemets faire le ménage dans les
dépenses fiscales existantes pour
évidemment à chaque fois qu'il en a eu
une inefficiente pouvoir la supprimer
mais ce sont souvent et chacun ici le
sait des débats assez long peut-être
dernière question particulière sur le
déplafonnement des contrats sur le
renouvelable donc moi je veux rappeler
le sens le l'état soutient le
développement des énergies renouvelables
via un complément de rémunération des
producteurs pour compenser le
différentiel entre les prix de marché et
un tarif de rachat et ce différentiel
est fixé pour rémunérer les exploitants
sur les risques qu'ils prennent il se
trouve que dans un contexte d'inflation
comme celui que nous connaissons ce
mécanisme peut se retrouver ce et se
renverser et devenir une forme d' effet
d'aubaine pour un certain nombre de
d'énergéticien et donc la hausse récente
des prix l'électricité a conduit à ce
que l'écart entre le prix garanti et les
prix du marché se résorbe voire même
s'inverse dès l'automne 2021 je pense
que le débat avait ici pour certains
gros contrats contrats ce qui implique
la restitution à l'état d'un
différentiel l'état donc se voit verser
de l'argent par les énergéticiens les
industriels toutefois il y avait
certains contrats signés entre 2016 et
2019 qui stipulait que le montant que
l'état pouvait récupérer dans ce cas là
étaient plafonnés à hauteur des sommes
versées antérieurement ce qui
engendrerait un manque à gagner pour
l'état dans le contexte de très forte
inflation des prix de l'énergie que nous
connaissons et dans le contexte que nous
connaissons nous n'aimons pas les
manques à gagner pour l'état c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons fait le
choix de proposer dans ce plfr de
déplafonner ces contrats pour la période
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre 2022 ce
qui représentera pour l'état de 4
milliards d'euros au titre de l'année
2022 je disais que c'est la dernière
question pardon il y avait un tout
dernier point qui avait été abordé par
monsieur
chair sur les os tp il me semble
effectivement effectivement on
fait comme toujours la constatation du
solde des suppressions de tp en
l'occurrence c'est 3951 sur la loi de
règlement
21 c'est principalement liée au
ministère de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports en raison 1 du
nombre de départs en retraite supérieur
à ce qui avait été prévu manifestement
et 2 et ça a été beaucoup commentée
récemment à des difficultés de
recrutement et d'autres activités ce qui
rend évidemment encore plus important le
chantier que nous avons ouvert sous la
responsabilité de mon collègue ministre
de l'éducation nationale de d'un choc
d'attractivité du métier d'enseignant
qui passe par une hausse des
rémunérations qu'a annoncé le président
de la république et qui passe aussi par
un trans forcement par rapport à une
transformation des missions et de
l'exercice du métier d'enseignant
chantier majeur du quinquennat qui a été
ouvert par mon collègue il ya aussi des
suppressions qui sont liées à des
transformations et à ce titre
permettez-moi d'indiquer que comme très
souvent et comme peut-être chaque année
le ministère de l'économie et des
finances est l'un des principaux
contributeurs puisque nous modernisons
nos fonctionnements ça a été le cas avec
le prélèvement à la source la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation la
suppression de la cap aussi va permettre
entre guillemets de rationaliser un
certain nombre de tp qui était dédiée à
la collecte au recouvrement de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public vous
poser la question sur la trajectoire et
sur ce qu'on prévoit là on est en plein
dans ce qui sera débattue et discuté
dans le cadre du programme de stabilité
et de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques moi je peux vous dire
quel est le mandat qui m'a été donnée
par la première ministre dans sa lettre
de cadrage le mandat qui m'a été donnée
c'est une stabilité des effectifs
publics sur le quinquennat stabilité ne
veut pas dire stabilité ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas d'évolution puisque je
vous rappelle que président de la
république s'est engagé à créer sur le
quinquennat 8500 poste pour le ministère
de la justice qu'un certain nombre de
créations sont prévus pour le ministère
de l'intérieur puisque nous avons dans
le cadre du bon goût de la sécurité un
objectif à horizon 2030 de doublement du
temps de présence des forces de l'ordre
sur la voie publique mais qui ne passera
pas que par des recrutements
supplémentaires qui passera aussi par la
réforme des cycles horaire par le
transfert d'un certain nombre de
missions sur des personnels
administratifs
je pense notamment au transfert de
détenus dans les hôpitaux je pense à la
garde de certains bâtiments publics etc
mais donc il va y avoir aussi du
redéploiement pour financer et pour
faire pour permettre ce doublement de la
présence des policiers sur la voie
publique mais il y aura aussi des
recrutements dont c'est stabilité
globale de l'emploi public sur le
quinquennat mais avec je le rappelle des
créations importantes qui sont prévus
dans les ministères régaliens je parlais
l'âge de la justice ministère de
l'intérieur il n'y a pas eu d'engagement
chiffré mais il y aura aussi des
créations et évidemment le ministère de
la défense avec une loi de programmation
militaire qui prévoit une augmentation
des moyens très importante et des
marches annuelles très important sur les
années à venir c'est ce que je discute
en ce moment même avec mes collègues du
gouvernement puisque en même temps que
nous avons ce projet de loi de finances
rectificatif sur 2022 j'ai les
conférences budgétaires avec mes
collègues du gouvernement pour préparer
le plf 23 et la lpfp je pense qu'avec
d'autres périodes où c'était plus sympa
pour reprendre votre terme pour le
ministre du budget d'être en face de ses
collègues mais en tout cas nous aurons
en discuter à la rentrée tous ensemble
merci monsieur mini jamais l'impression
que cette dominati avait pas eu la
réponse à ces questions c'est ça
elle n'était qu'en partie et le ministre
vient simplement de l'évoquer or sur le
dernier quinquennat le président de la
république avait dit puisque vous citez
souvent président à un public moins
50000 emplois dans la fonction publique
d'état cinquante mille pour les
collectivités territoriales
donc qu'est ce qui a changé pour le
prochain quinquennat puisque vous nous
dites stabilité sur les cinq ans qui
viennent qu'est ce qui a changé entre le
premier mandat ou président de la
république avait dit pour rétablir nos
dépenses publiques nous allons supprimer
50 mille emplois et dans ce second
quinquennat si je comprends bien votre
objectif c'est de le maintenir l'emploi
à ce niveau là alors que vous vous et
d'affirmer le discours de réduction de
la dépense publique mais vous ne touchez
pas au principal poste de l'état qui 80%
qu'est ce qui a changé
question sauf si le ministre veut qu'on
ouvre un débat maintenant mais j'ai
compris qu'il allait je veux répondre je
veux bien répondre rapidement à qui on
aura le débat de toute façon
non non c'est vrai c'est un sujet
important
monsieur dominati ce voile à redon
messieurs
on aura le débat dans le cadre de la lfp
mais pour moi ce qui a changé c'est deux
choses effectivement en 2017 c'est sa
compagne déjà à l'époque le président de
la république candidat à l'époque
s'était engagé sur un objectif chiffré
de réduction des effectifs publics dans
le premier quinquennat il s'est passé un
certain nombre de choses notamment la
crise des gilets jaunes qui nous a
conduits à acter un renforcement de nos
services publics sur le territoire et à
l'époque il a donc été assumée que cet
engagement de 2017 été transformé en un
autre c'est de déconcentrer de
relocaliser au maximum des services
publics dans les territoires et non plus
d'avoir un objectif chiffré de réduction
du nombre de postes de fonctionnaires la
deuxième chose c'est la campagne
présidentielle et d'ailleurs le
président de la république dans la
campagne a été interrogé sur cet
objectif de l'époque qui l'avaient de
données notamment sur le fait que
d'autres candidats et en l'occurrence
une candidate avait elle fixé un
objectif chiffré pour le quinquennat qui
s'ouvre et il a indiqué très clairement
que ce qui s'était passé dans le cours
du premier quinquennat l'avait conduit à
repenser effectivement les choses et à
considérer désormais que ce ne sont plus
ce n'est plus un chiffre objectifs de
réduction de postes qui doit nous
conduire à faire des réformes
structurelles mes pensées des réformes
structurelles qui produisent ensuite des
économies sur les postes principalement
pour pouvoir les redéployer ailleurs au
service de la protection des français
c'est ce qu'on a fait est que le
prélèvement à la source par exemple
c'est ce qu'on va proposer de faire avec
un certain nombre de réformes et je
constate d'ailleurs que les candidats en
l'occurrence la candidate qui se
présentait dans le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle avec un objectif de je
crois cent cinquante mille suppressions
de postes de fonctionnaires n'a jamais
été capable je parle même pas que je
parle pas du résultat électoral mais n'a
jamais été capable de dire où est ce
qu'elle les prenait voilà donc encore
une fois on a cet objectif de l'objectif
de stabilité ne veut pas dire qu'il y
aura des réformes qu'il n'y aura pas de
réforme plutôt puisque si on veut
pouvoir renforcer dans la justice dans
la police dans les armées il faut bien
que l'on fasse des réformes pour
évidemment trouver les marges pour le
faire et ce sera le débat du de la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
merci monsieur le ministre vous nous
avez donné rendez-vous avec un certain
nombre d'échéances le programme de
stabilité la loi d'orientation des
finances publiques le plf je pense que
ce en outre sans trahir la pensée du
président et celle du rapporteur général
si vous venez nous voir en amont qu'on
ait le temps de discuter ça évitera
peut-être on peut passer tout le mois
d'août ensemble qu'ils avaient vu on a
eu lundi un dialogue intéressant ce
matin
voilà déjà on sera déjà là avec vous en
août au qu'on est prêt
le 26 juillet dans l'hémicycle du sénat
donc ça serait bien que le document on
les a pas le 25 après midi il a reçu
normalement le passant